Hi, Josh, Craig and Alec.
嗨，乔什、克雷格和亚历克。
My name is Lisa.
我叫丽莎。
I'm 24 from Austria and I just wrapped up traveling through Australia for six months by myself, which was quite the rollercoaster.
我今年 24 岁，来自奥地利，刚刚独自结束了澳大利亚六个月的旅行，这真是像坐过山车一样。
I've always looked at your show as a comfort show and during my travels, I found the rewatch podcast and I got to be honest, I might have binged every single episode in an embarrassingly short amount of time and I might have already listened to a bunch of it twice as well.
我一直把你的节目视为安慰节目，在我的旅行中，我发现了重播播客，说实话，我可能在令人尴尬的短时间内把每一集都看完了，而且我可能已经把其中的一堆听了两遍。
So you guys have spent countless hours of driving through Australia with me.
你们花了无数个小时和我一起驾车穿越澳大利亚。
I love how you dissect the episodes and as someone who is fascinated by filmmaking.
我喜欢你对情节的剖析，以及作为一个对电影制作着迷的人。
I love all the behind the scenes, details and how you shot certain things.
我喜欢所有的幕后花絮、细节以及你如何拍摄某些东西。
I'm not the most mentally stable person as well, so whenever I didn't want to hear my own thoughts, I found great comfort in listening to yours.
我也不是一个心理最稳定的人，所以每当我不想听到自己的想法时，听你的想法会让我感到很大的安慰。
I started to admit my interest in acting to myself doing my travels.
我开始承认我有兴趣在旅行中为自己表演。
I currently study electrical engineering, so we'll see if I ever have to courage to pursue that dream.
我目前学习电气工程，所以我们会看看我是否有勇气去追求这个梦想。
Well anyways, thank you for everything you do.
无论如何，谢谢你所做的一切。
I'm looking forward to all of the episodes to come.
我期待着接下来的所有剧集。
I'm alone.
我还是孤单一人。
Don't be super book city.
不要成为超级书城。
When I see, please permit me to tell you everything.
当我看到时，请允许我告诉你一切。
Craig, how about that?
克雷格，那怎么样？
We were keeping an Austrian woman company on her six-month trip through Australia.
我们陪伴一位奥地利女性进行为期六个月的澳大利亚之旅。
I mean, I feel like we were there with her or we were there with her, we got all the benefits of that trip.
我的意思是，我觉得我们和她在一起，或者我们和她在一起，我们得到了那次旅行的所有好处。
We got all the benefits.
我们得到了所有的好处。
We were somehow there with her.
我们不知何故就在她身边。
I love it, I fucking love it.
我喜欢它，我他妈的喜欢它。
Hemium has traveled the world.
Hemium 已经走遍了世界。
Now this podcast is traveling the world.
现在这个播客正在世界各地传播。
There's something very, very cool about the energy of that.
这种能量非常非常酷。
And speaking of energy, this is our second, I'm gonna be just, I'm gonna pull back the curtain.
说到能量，这是我们的第二次，我要拉开帷幕。
This is our second record of the night.
这是我们当晚的第二张唱片。
We're doing these at night, Josh is a little baby and we're doing it at night once the baby's asleep.
我们在晚上做这些，乔希是一个小婴儿，我们在晚上婴儿睡着后做这些。
And there's our second one and we're like a little, we're like, all right, we gotta get energy up.
这是我们的第二个，我们就像一点，我们就像，好吧，我们必须补充能量。
The second I hear a story like that, the second Alec hits play and it's this message that Josh and I have never heard, and it's a Hymn fan and a Hymn fan saying, you were in Australia with me?
当我听到这样的故事时，亚历克第二次按下播放键，这是我和乔什从未听过的消息，这是一个赞美诗歌迷和一个赞美诗歌迷说，你和我一起在澳大利亚吗？
I instantly have energy again.
我立刻又有了能量。
I also love that now that people aren't just binging the show.
我也喜欢现在人们不再只是追剧。
Now they're binging the podcast about going back over episodes, it's great.
现在他们正在播放关于回顾剧集的播客，这太棒了。
It's a real honor to us.
这对我们来说是一种真正的荣幸。
That's the best part of it.
这是它最好的部分。
Going to Australia with you is the best part of it.
和你一起去澳大利亚是其中最好的部分。
So thank you.
所以谢谢你。
I feel an infusion of some energy from that, just from that message.
仅仅从那条信息中，我就感受到了一些能量的注入。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Welcome to how we made your mother, I'm Josh Radner.
欢迎来到我们如何造就你的母亲，我是乔什·拉德纳。
This is Craig Thomas.
这是克雷格·托马斯。
My dear friend, Alec Lev is with us.
我亲爱的朋友，亚历克·列夫（Alec Lev）和我们在一起。
Our intrepid producer.
我们勇敢的制片人。
I don't even know what that means, but people always say our intrepid producer.
我什至不知道这意味着什么，但人们总是说我们勇敢的制片人。
You're intrepid.
你真勇敢。
You just played us an Austrian woman talking about Australia.
你刚刚给我们扮演了一位谈论澳大利亚的奥地利女人。
That's fucking intrepid of you.
你真是太大胆了
That was intrepid as all get out.
当所有人都出去时，这真是勇敢。
Yeah.
是的。
So yes, as Craig mentioned, we are pulling a two for tonight, But I also just got back from five or six days in Mexico with my wife and our baby.
所以，是的，正如克雷格提到的，我们今晚要拉两个，但我也刚刚和我的妻子和孩子从墨西哥待了五六天回来。
We went to a dear friend's wedding.
我们去参加了一位好朋友的婚礼。
This couple met the same weekend that Jordana and I met.
这对夫妇是在我和乔丹娜认识的同一个周末认识的。
This is Jordana's best friend, Ellie and they met her now husband, Nima, the same weekend Jordana and I met.
这是乔丹娜最好的朋友艾莉，他们在我和乔丹娜认识的同一个周末认识了她现在的丈夫尼玛。
And so we were there to celebrate them.
所以我们在那里庆祝他们。
And there was a morning where, I think, was it the morning of, no, this is the morning, the morning before the wedding.
有一个早晨，我想，是不是，不，这是早晨，婚礼前的早晨。
And I see this woman, I know Christina, and she's talking to someone.
我看到这个女人，我认识克里斯蒂娜，她正在和某人说话。
And this woman says, Josh, Brenda Shae from How I Met Your Mother.
这个女人说，乔什，《老爸老妈的浪漫史》中的布伦达·谢伊。
Brenda Shae, one of the writers on How I Met Your Mother who wrote classics such as The Slutty Pumpkin.
布伦达·谢伊 (Brenda Shae)，《老爸老妈浪漫史》的编剧之一，曾创作过《放荡的南瓜》等经典作品。
And today's episode, do we sit triple?
今天的节目，我们坐三人吗？
Jovis the triple, yeah.
乔维斯三人组，是的。
was at this wedding for my friends.
参加了我朋友的婚礼。
She knew Nima back in San Francisco.
她在旧金山就认识尼玛了。
Yeah.
是的。
It's really strange that that's who we were right about to record this episode and there she is in Mexico, which is so weird, it's very cool.
真的很奇怪，这就是我们要录制这一集的人，而她却在墨西哥，这太奇怪了，这非常酷。
Yes, and yeah, and this is why I'm struggling a little bit.
是的，是的，这就是为什么我有点挣扎。
But you're asleep.
但你睡着了。
No, yesterday was just a travel day for like a comically, like I told you guys about the stroller mishap and the delayed flights.
不，昨天只是一个旅行日，滑稽的是，就像我告诉你们婴儿车事故和航班延误一样。
And when you have a six month old, that stuff takes a toll.
当你有六个月大的孩子时，这些东西就会产生影响。
But it's like, he has an excuse, he's a baby.
但就像，他有一个借口，他还是个孩子。
Like, what about us who are about to burst into tears?
比如说，我们这些快要泪流满面的人呢？
Like, it was tough, but we're happy to be home.
就像，这很艰难，但我们很高兴回到家。
Respect to you and Jordana from going to Mexico for a destination wedding when you, you had such a good excuse in this young little baby boy to not go down.
向你和乔丹娜去墨西哥参加目的地婚礼表示敬意，当你在这个年轻的小男孩身上有一个很好的借口不去的时候。
This is like a, I think she had to go.
这就像一个，我想她必须走。
She had to go.
她必须走了。
And also her brother's getting married in Brazil.
她的哥哥也即将在巴西结婚。
like in like two weeks, which we also can't miss.
大约两周后，我们也不能错过。
So we're going to be doing another one of these.
所以我们将做其中的另一件事。
I know.
我知道。
I wonder what Hemium writer you'll meet then.
我想知道那时你会遇到哪位 Hemium 作家。
Whoever we're going to talk about their episode next is going to be at that wedding.
无论我们接下来要谈论的人是谁，他都会参加那场婚礼。
That's really crazy.
这真的很疯狂。
Well, yes, Brenda Shea, we're a very good Hemium writer.
嗯，是的，Brenda Shea，我们是一位非常优秀的 Hemium 作家。
She's on all the first three seasons.
前三季她都参加了。
And she wrote today's episode and much respect to Brenda.
她写了今天的节目，并向布伦达致以崇高的敬意。
She's a very good writer.
她是一位非常好的作家。
And she wrote them the Pixar movie Elemental, since that's Brenda had a very cool.
她为他们写了皮克斯电影《元素》，因为布伦达非常酷。
That's why she was in San Francisco and that's what she met Neema.
这就是她来到旧金山的原因，也是她认识尼玛的原因。
Yeah, that's actually my, your friend.
是的，那实际上是我的，你的朋友。
Yeah, so, and so, and speaking of which, Hemium, I have this little grid we made at one point.
是的，如此，如此，说到这一点，Hemium，我有一个我们曾经制作过的小网格。
Hemium writers, Hemium writers have done some fucking cool things.
Hemium 作家，Hemium 作家做了一些他妈的很酷的事情。
Can I do a little sidebar about this?
我可以为此做一个小侧边栏吗？
I'm gonna do a little sidebar, ready?
我要做一个小侧边栏，准备好了吗？
Josh, you're tired, you take a brief nap during this.
乔什，你累了，你在这期间小睡一下。
I would have anyway, you didn't tell me.
反正我会的，你没告诉我。
Whatever I get more than two sentences deep, I'm gonna leave now.
无论我得到超过两句话的深度，我现在就要离开。
Brenda Shea, elemental.
布伦达·谢伊，元素。
We made this little grid of like amazing things Hemium writers, but these are other credits since I met your mother, the new Naked Gun movie, Dan Doug.
我们制作了这个小网格，里面有 Hemium 作家的一些令人惊奇的东西，但这些是自从我遇见你的母亲、新的《裸枪》电影丹·道格以来的其他作品。
They wrote that.
他们这样写的。
Chris and Phil, they just did Project Hail Mary.
克里斯和菲尔，他们刚刚完成了万福玛丽计划。
I was at the premiere party for Project Hail Mary and ran into your friends who just got married at that premiere party because they're apparently everywhere.
我参加了《万福玛丽计划》的首映派对，并遇到了刚刚在首映派对上结婚的朋友，因为他们显然无处不在。
Everything about this is weirdly overlapping.
关于这一切的一切都奇怪地重叠。
What else do we do?
我们还能做什么？
Glory, Collar, and Kelly created one day at a time, that reboot, just like, I'm just very proud of like the amazing work that like how I met your mother, writers have gone on to do it.
格洛里、科拉和凯利一天又创作了一部重启作品，就像我对这部令人惊叹的作品感到非常自豪，就像我如何认识你母亲一样，作家们继续这样做。
Dave Hemmingson wrote The Holdovers, got an Oscar nomination.
戴夫·海明森 (Dave Hemmingson) 创作了《保留》(The Holdovers)，并获得奥斯卡提名。
He was just on with us a couple episodes ago, just like the coolest credits, Joe Kelly co-created Ted Lasso and Detroiters, since I met your mother ended.
几集前，他刚刚和我们一起出现过，就像最酷的片尾字幕一样，乔·凯利与人共同创作了《泰德·拉索》和《底特律》，自从我遇见你妈妈结束后。
Just, I don't know, I just wanna shout out some of the Robbie Rashid, an amazing show called Atypical, just like very cool shit and Brenda writing for Pixar.
只是，我不知道，我只是想大声喊出罗比·拉希德（Robbie Rashid）的一些内容，这是一部名为“非典型”的精彩节目，就像非常酷的狗屎和布伦达为皮克斯写作一样。
So I just, I'm very proud of the Hemium alum writers and all they've gone on to do.
所以我只是，我为 Hemium 校友作家和他们所做的一切感到非常自豪。
Yeah, you know, there's a grand history in Hollywood of like certain writer's rooms having, you know, like Ben Stiller's show.
是的，你知道，好莱坞有一段悠久的历史，就像某些作家的房间里有本·斯蒂勒的演出一样。
Right?
正确的？
Early SNL or I think.
早期的周六夜现场或者我认为。
The Dana, kind of failed Dana Carby's sketch show at one of those writing steps.
达纳（Dana），在其中一个写作步骤中，达纳·卡比（Dana Carby）的素描展有点失败。
It's just like unbelievable.
简直难以置信。
Yeah.
是的。
So this episode is called The Waste of Treepla.
所以这一集被称为“Treepla的浪费”。
You know what's funny?
你知道什么好笑吗？
We always talk about, and we always talk about how we met your mother is a mystery, but a lot of episodes begin with something mysterious happening, like brunch, you know, where like, Why is everyone being weird?
我们总是谈论，我们总是谈论我们如何认识你母亲是一个谜，但很多剧集都是以一些神秘的事情开始，比如早午餐，你知道，比如，为什么每个人都很奇怪？
Yeah.
是的。
This title is a mystery.
这个标题是一个谜。
Yeah.
是的。
That is not solved until the very end.
这个问题直到最后才得到解决。
The very, very end.
非常非常的结束。
And I thought, I said to Joanna when we're watching, I said, did they say what it stood for?
我想，当我们观看时，我对乔安娜说，他们有说它代表什么吗？
And she's like, I don't think so.
她说，我不这么认为。
But I was like, oh, that's the whole punch line of the episode.
但我当时想，哦，这就是这一集的全部妙语。
That's the entire thing it's building towards.
这就是它的全部目标。
I love how you watch these episodes.
我喜欢你看这些剧集的方式。
And your next to your wife who's never seen the show.
还有你旁边的你妻子，她从未看过这部剧。
And you're both completely clueless about what's going to happen.
你们都对将要发生的事情一无所知。
And like, she's like, what's going to happen?
就像，她想，会发生什么？
I'm like, don't look at me.
我就说，别看我。
I don't write.
我不写。
It was a long time ago.
那是很久以前的事了。
That's why when fans come up to you with super specific questions and I'm like, I'm better able to answer them now.
这就是为什么当粉丝们向你提出非常具体的问题时，我想，我现在能够更好地回答他们了。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思？
Like for years, I was like, I don't even remember what you're talking about.
就像多年来，我什至不记得你在说什么。
Like this is like, I loved a few episodes ago.
就像这样，我很喜欢前几集。
You're like, and I turned to Jordan, and I'm like, I think I know what the twist is gonna be.
你就像，我转向乔丹，我想，我想我知道会发生什么转折。
I'm like, yeah, you fucking do.
我想，是的，你他妈的就是这样。
You know what the twist is gonna be.
你知道会有什么转折。
No man, I wasn't sure.
没有，我不确定。
I was like, maybe I have a memory.
我当时想，也许我有记忆。
Maybe that's it.
也许就是这样。
I thought I had solved it.
我以为我已经解决了。
I didn't even remember.
我什至不记得了。
I thought I was like intuiting it.
我以为我有直觉。
I'd most be boys that.
我最想成为男孩。
You most be boys.
你们大多数都是男孩。
Oh, well, I love that so much.
哦，好吧，我非常喜欢这个。
And by the way, I am having every episode.
顺便说一句，我正在观看每一集。
There's multiple things where I go, oh, I completely forgot that.
我去了很多事情，哦，我完全忘记了。
Or I forgot that that happened in this episode.
或者我忘记了这一集中发生的事情。
But yeah, I really like this episode a lot.
但是，是的，我真的很喜欢这一集。
So, do we sit your blood?
那么，我们坐你的血吗？
Alec, tell us when this episode aired?
亚历克，告诉我们这一集什么时候播出？
This episode aired on November 5th, 2007.
本集于2007年11月5日播出。
Okay.
好的。
And Craig, this is a little bit, I would say, sometimes we look at these episodes, we go, oh, this is actually a two-parter in certain ways, you know?
克雷格，这有点，我想说，有时我们看这些剧集，我们会说，哦，这实际上在某些方面是两人合作的，你知道吗？
This is part two of this kind of Lily Marshall economic anxiety, kind of a cliffhangerish at the end of the day.
这是莉莉·马歇尔这种经济焦虑的第二部分，归根结底是一种悬念。
It was unresolved in the previous episode, which is on not that guy.
上一集没有解决这个问题，这不是那个人的事。
And I really love how Marshall and Lily have this legitimate financial huge problem.
我真的很喜欢马歇尔和莉莉如何解决这个合法的巨大财务问题。
And Lillie has a secret, Marshall doesn't even know they're in these dire financial straits because Lillie's carrying around this huge secret.
莉莉有一个秘密，马歇尔甚至不知道他们陷入了如此可怕的财务困境，因为莉莉随身携带着这个巨大的秘密。
And I really like that you come into this episode with like this ticking time bomb of suspense.
我真的很喜欢你带着这个定时炸弹般的悬念进入这一集。
And so yeah, the three big threads in this episode are Marshall and Lillie being in this huge fiasco that Marshall doesn't know Lillie has run up this enormous debt due to this like shopping addiction.
所以，是的，这一集中的三大线索是马歇尔和莉莉陷入了这场巨大的惨败，马歇尔不知道莉莉因为购物成瘾而背负了巨额债务。
We see her at a meeting.
我们在一次会议上见到她。
We literally see her at like a meeting for shopping addicts in this episode.
在这一集里，我们确实看到她就像在一次购物狂聚会上。
And they decide, they make the terrible, terrible decision to go in way over their heads and buy an apartment because they do, they make the textbook mistake of day one, they see one thing and they go, we have to have this.
他们决定，他们做出了一个可怕的决定，超出了他们的想象，买了一套公寓，因为他们这样做了，他们在第一天就犯了教科书上的错误，他们看到了一件事，然后就走了，我们必须拥有这个。
And by the way, I've absolutely done that.
顺便说一句，我绝对做到了。
I am the guy that like will buy the first thing I see.
我是那种看到第一眼就会买的人。
I have that part of Marshall is like me.
我觉得马歇尔的那一部分就像我一样。
So that's basically we're watching them over commit financially and Marshall doesn't even know that they're massively in debt.
所以基本上我们正在观察他们在财务上的过度承诺，​​而马歇尔甚至不知道他们负债累累。
And I love the way the suspense of that in this episode, it all comes out.
我喜欢这一集的悬念，一切都浮现出来。
Barney runs a very sociopathic side scheme where the apartment that his dear friends are trying to purchase.
巴尼经营着一个非常反社会的副业计划，其中他亲爱的朋友们正试图购买公寓。
He realizes he can pretend to be an interested buyer, steal the apartment key or the code password to get in as if he's a buyer who wants to see it when the realtor can't show it and just have sex with a woman in the apartment that his dear friends are going to try to buy and read the family.
他意识到他可以假装是一个有兴趣的买家，偷走公寓钥匙或代码密码进入，就好像他是一个买家，在房地产经纪人无法出示时想要看到它，然后在他亲爱的朋友将要尝试购买的公寓里与一个女人发生性关系并阅读家庭。
Not Barney's finest hour.
这不是巴尼最好的时刻。
It's not as fun as Sarah, and he doesn't have a come up in this episode.
它不像莎拉那么有趣，而且他在这一集中没有出现。
I actually really miss, because we've been pretty good at tracking, like, well, when he goes too far, the sort of moral universe of the show is pretty good at giving him karma.
我真的很怀念，因为我们一直非常擅长追踪，就像，好吧，当他走得太远时，该剧的道德宇宙非常擅长给他业力。
There is no repercussion in this one for as should he is.
这件事没有产生任何影响，因为他应该如此。
I could make an argument for the fact that when he, when he, this is way jumping head, so forgive me.
我可以提出一个论点，因为当他，当他，这是一种跳跃的方式，所以请原谅我。
When he hears and fears that Marshall and Lily they're getting divorced and it devastates him.
当他听说并担心马歇尔和莉莉要离婚时，他感到很沮丧。
No, that, I think there's something about the fact that he's been such a slimy shithead in this episode.
不，我认为他在这一集里是一个如此粘糊糊的混蛋这一事实是有一定道理的。
That the thought that this one couple that actually is kind of carrying the torch for like his sentimental view of a good relationship, even though he makes fun of it all the time.
想到这一对夫妇实际上有点像他对良好关系的感伤看法，尽管他总是取笑它。
And are like his parents, they're his model for like a good, happy couple.
就像他的父母一样，他们是他的榜样，就像一对幸福的夫妻。
They're parenting Barney in some ways.
他们在某些方面正在养育巴尼。
It's the Barney that says there's gonna be a baby.
巴尼说将会有一个孩子。
Yeah, it's that Barney, yes.
是的，就是那个巴尼，是的。
Really like you're right Barney's energy shifts in a really good way and also Barney is very much Cowed by Ted Barney is very into Ted This is Ted's little runner in this episode where Ted is a detective Ted is sighing the the and he's got his back fully Yes, yes exactly yeah, yeah, and like so and Barney really becomes Ted second in command He's really he really immediately looks up to dad So in the second half of this episode, after being a total shit, Barney does do a couple of things that are sort of like winning and sort of weirdly sweet.
真的就像你说得对，巴尼的能量以一种非常好的方式转变，而且巴尼非常被泰德吓倒 巴尼非常喜欢泰德 这是泰德在这一集里的小跑步者，泰德是一名侦探 泰德叹了口气，他完全得到了支持 是的，是的，完全是的，是的，就像这样，巴尼真的成为了泰德的第二把手 他真的他真的立即仰望爸爸 所以在这一集的后半部分，在成为总指挥之后妈的，巴尼确实做了一些类似获胜而且有点奇怪的甜蜜的事情。
And he's definitely like willing to be Ted's like second in command in this crime scene they're investigating.
他绝对愿意成为特德在他们正在调查的犯罪现场的二把手。
Yeah.
是的。
But those are the three threads.
但这是三个线程。
I do like, I like that even though they're kind of three little runners, you know, there's two runners off a main story.
我确实喜欢，我喜欢这样，尽管他们是三个小跑步者，你知道，主线故事中有两个跑步者。
It's all off when this one big main story, the apartment that these people are purchasing who cannot afford it, and there's this huge secret.
当这一个大的主要故事发生时，一切都结束了，这些人买不起公寓，而且有一个巨大的秘密。
Everything kind of does come from that in this episode, which I like.
一切都来自这一集，我喜欢这一集。
And I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you in New York City.
我给你写了这首小曲，是为了在纽约唱给你听。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
And now, back to the show.
现在，回到节目。
There's something about Marshall and Lily, like they go first a lot.
马歇尔和莉莉身上有一些东西，就像他们经常先行一样。
Like they're the ones who go first.
就好像他们是第一个走的人一样。
They're the first ones to be in a committed relationship.
他们是第一批建立忠诚关系的人。
First ones get married.
第一个结婚。
up into space ahead of everybody.
先于所有人进入太空。
Yeah.
是的。
Exactly.
确切地。
And this thing of like, not just trying to rent an apartment, but buy an apartment, like they're in such like adult weeds here.
就像这样的事情，不仅仅是想租一套公寓，而是买一套公寓，就像他们在这里的成年杂草一样。
Yeah.
是的。
That they're just overwhelmed.
他们只是不知所措。
And yeah.
是的。
And also, I mean, it's really funny what and we'll get here, but like tries to make this kind of like reactionary patriarchal argument, like I shouldn't even be a part of this.
而且，我的意思是，这真的很有趣，我们将到达这里，但就像试图提出这种反动的父权制争论，就像我什至不应该参与其中一样。
Can women even vote?
女性也可以投票吗？
Why do?
为什么要这样做？
Yeah.
是的。
It's so funny.
太搞笑了。
Yeah.
是的。
So I love this look for Lily.
所以我很喜欢莉莉的这个造型。
I love that she is just in the wrong.
我喜欢她只是错了。
She really fucked up.
她真的完蛋了。
And she has to come clean.
她必须坦白。
It's going to come out one way or the other.
它会以一种或另一种方式出现。
And she really she lets it come out the worst way possible.
她确实让事情以最糟糕的方式发生。
They go in to actually like try to get the loan and it comes out like by a bank officer looking up her credit history.
他们实际上想尝试获得贷款，结果就像银行官员查找她的信用记录一样。
And that's when and she says, I wanted to be the first one to tell you this Marshall, which is hilarious.
就在那时，她说，我想成为第一个告诉你这个马歇尔的人，这很搞笑。
She so does not do the right thing in this delightful way.
她并没有以这种令人愉快的方式做正确的事。
By the way, the bank loan officer was hilarious.
顺便说一句，银行信贷员很搞笑。
He's great.
他很棒。
He was so funny.
他真是太有趣了。
Like the way he was laughing with Marshall and like his just like geniality and the whole thing was just really funny.
就像他和马歇尔一起笑的方式，喜欢他的友善，整件事真的很有趣。
Really, really funny, really natural and real.
真的，真的很有趣，真的很自然，很真实。
Like that is a good, you could study that little guest performance and be like, that's what you come in and do.
就像这是一件好事，你可以研究一下嘉宾的表演，然后说，这就是你进来要做的事情。
You parachute into a show and you just go all in and you just play it and you just be part of, he was so effortlessly part of that scene, that actor.
你跳伞进入一场演出，你全力以赴，你只是扮演它，你只是其中的一部分，他是那个场景的一部分，那个演员。
We should look up his name and give him his proper tributes, Alec is on it, I can see him doing it as we speak.
我们应该查一下他的名字，并向他致敬，亚历克就在上面，在我们说话的时候我可以看到他正在这样做。
There's also something like, I wasn't there, when we filmed that obviously, I wasn't in the scene, I was probably at home, I wasn't on set even.
还有一些事情，比如，我不在那里，当我们拍摄时，显然，我不在场景中，我可能在家里，我什至不在片场。
And if I didn't watch this episode, which there's no guarantee I did because I didn't watch a lot of the episodes, that was the first time I saw that performance, you know?
如果我没有看这一集（这不能保证我看了，因为我没有看很多集），那是我第一次看到那个表演，你知道吗？
unless he was there at the run through, which I don't remember if he was.
除非他在跑步时在场，但我不记得他是否在场。
He might've been able to run through probably, unless of course he wasn't, and we hadn't cast out Rolli yet or something, but yeah, that's hilarious.
他也许能够跑过去，当然，除非他不能，而且我们还没有赶走罗利什么的，但是，是的，这太搞笑了。
You know what else was good in this is Meg, poor Meg, that Barney is just fooling.
你知道梅格还有什么好处，可怜的梅格，巴尼只是在愚弄。
She's really wants a commitment, and he's just such a shit to her.
她真的想要一个承诺，而他对她来说就是个废物。
She was funny at that actress.
她对那个女演员很有趣。
She was good.
她很好。
Was that April?
那是四月吗？
April, yeah.
四月，是啊。
Were you friends with her?
你和她是朋友吗？
I feel like you knew that.
我感觉你好像知道这一点。
I would see her over the years as she was always delightful.
多年来我都会见到她，因为她总是令人愉快。
I think she was friends with Kobe.
我认为她和科比是朋友。
Yeah, I feel like she was friends with somebody on the cast.
是的，我觉得她和剧组里的某个人是朋友。
Yeah, she was great.
是的，她很棒。
No, she was really funny.
不，她真的很有趣。
And you know, those Barney girlfriend roles like could, I thought that the actresses who played them often made a lot of them, you know?
你知道，那些巴尼女朋友的角色就像可以，我认为扮演这些角色的女演员经常制作很多这样的角色，你知道吗？
Like they could have been like kind of like dim, you know, kind of just girl of the week kind of energy.
就像她们本来可以有点像昏暗的，你知道的，有点像本周的女孩那样的能量。
And she really brought something very sweet and open and It made it so much worse in the best in a good way.
她确实带来了一些非常甜蜜和开放的东西，这在最好的情况下以一种好的方式让事情变得更糟。
Yes, but she was also like really alert to her own.
是的，但她对自己也非常警惕。
She was alert to her own damage, you know, like as a character.
她对自己的伤害很警惕，你知道，就像作为一个角色一样。
Yeah, she very much was.
是的，她非常是。
Okay.
好的。
It was Phil Lewis played the lone officer.
菲尔·刘易斯扮演了孤独的军官。
I guess April Bulby played April Bulby.
我猜阿普丽尔·布尔比扮演了阿普丽尔·布尔比。
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的。
They were both great in this episode.
他们在这一集中都表现出色。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, and there's this mystery.
是的，还有这个谜团。
What does Debus of Chippewa mean?
奇珀瓦的德布斯是什么意思？
I really liked the running device of is what he should have said or is what she should have said or is what we should have said.
我真的很喜欢他应该说的话，或者她应该说的话，或者我们应该说的话。
That was a very satisfying storytelling device that really was like this episode's thing and the little fantasy pops about how they I like seeing also the Marshall Lilly weren't completely on the same page about their future the four kids the two kids lilies has a secret.
这是一个非常令人满意的讲故事的装置，真的就像这一集的东西，我喜欢看到马歇尔·莉莉对他们的未来也没有完全达成一致的小幻想，四个孩子，两个孩子莉莉有一个秘密。
I like how this presents like they are just happy excited young married couple but she does not absolutely paradise perfect you know she has a huge secret and they're making a terrible decision that's really going to complicate their lives and I like it because it gives you you can we're setting up stuff for the whole season with this apart.
我喜欢这个呈现方式，就像他们只是幸福兴奋的年轻已婚夫妇，但她并不是绝对完美的天堂，你知道她有一个巨大的秘密，他们正在做出一个可怕的决定，这真的会让他们的生活变得复杂，我喜欢它，因为它让你可以我们为整个季节准备一些东西。
and a huge decision and this huge problem they have.
这是一个重大的决定，也是他们面临的一个巨大的问题。
Well, it's also real estate.
嗯，这也是房地产。
We want it to be incredibly logical.
我们希望它具有令人难以置信的逻辑性。
It is a highly emotional thing.
这是一件高度情绪化的事情。
Totally.
完全。
Buying property, you know, like buying property and saying like, this is where we're gonna live.
购买房产，你知道，就像购买房产然后说，这就是我们要住的地方。
This is where we're gonna raise our children.
这是我们要抚养孩子的地方。
This is one of the most emotional things you can do.
这是你能做的最情绪化的事情之一。
Like moving, buying apartments and moving.
比如搬家、买公寓、搬家。
It's so displacement.
真是位移啊
It's one of the top three stressors.
它是三大压力源之一。
It's one of the way up there.
这是通往那里的道路之一。
Yeah.
是的。
I like that, I like that what you said about Marshall and Lilly being the first.
我喜欢这一点，我喜欢你所说的马歇尔和莉莉是第一个。
like they're the like chimp sent up into space to see if it's possible for like humans to then go.
就像他们就像黑猩猩被送上太空，看看是否有可能像人类一样去太空。
They serve that role in this group in this interesting way.
他们以这种有趣的方式在这个群体中扮演这个角色。
And they're having to make, they're not only going first, they're making the mistake first.
他们必须做到，他们不仅要先走，而且要先犯错误。
They're making huge mistakes.
他们犯了巨大的错误。
They're stepping in it, you know?
他们正在介入，你知道吗？
I really liked jumping all over here, but I really liked Marshall's, Marshall finds out his wife lied to him and ran up a huge debt.
我真的很喜欢在这里跳来跳去，但我真的很喜欢马歇尔的，马歇尔发现他的妻子对他撒了谎，并欠下了巨额债务。
And I like the mystery of what happened, Why did they place the call to a divorce lawyer?
我喜欢所发生的事情的神秘性，为什么他们打电话给离婚律师？
And it's very funny that she's, that was her solution.
很有趣的是，这就是她的解决方案。
She's like, if we get divorced, you can just buy the apartment in your name.
她说，如果我们离婚，你可以用你的名字买这套公寓。
But I like, which was a funny weird twist.
但我喜欢，这是一个有趣而奇怪的转折。
And it was there to be like a mislead about them getting divorced, Barney falling apart was hilarious.
这就像关于他们离婚的误导一样，巴尼的崩溃很搞笑。
I liked the sentiment, Marshall said, of when I married you, I also married all your problems.
马歇尔说，我喜欢这种感觉，当我嫁给你时，我也解决了你所有的问题。
I married all the good parts, but I also married all your problems.
我娶了所有好的部分，但我也娶了你所有的问题。
I'm not going to run from those problems.
我不会逃避这些问题。
I know I didn't know about this one, but I did sign up for this.
我知道我不知道这个，但我确实注册了这个。
just like you signed up for whatever my shit is.
就像你报名参加我的狗屎一样。
He's not good at buying an apartment, but he's very good at being a husband when the chips are down.
他不擅长买房，但他很擅长在危急时刻做丈夫。
Yeah.
是的。
I love what he said there.
我喜欢他在那里说的话。
And Siegel played that great, and that does make you love them.
西格尔的演奏非常出色，这确实让你喜欢他们。
But Lily really messed up.
但莉莉实在是太糟糕了。
Lily really, when he was saying that Jordana was watching it very stressed out, being like, this is really bad.
莉莉真的，当他说乔丹娜观看比赛时压力很大，就像，这真的很糟糕。
So stressed and only got more stressed in this episode.
压力很大，而且在这一集中压力更大。
Part of the emotionality of buying a place, especially if you're newly married and want to start a family, the flash forwards of them with their kids and the difference between what they're seeing and what they're feeling, like Marshall, you know, leading the Erickson family players in the band.
买房的部分情感因素，尤其是当你刚结婚并想要组建家庭时，他们和孩子的闪现以及他们所看到的和他们所感受到的之间的差异，就像马歇尔，你知道，在乐队中领导埃里克森家族的球员。
Yes.
是的。
And then Lily's kids are, of course, great visual artists and they're going to be showing at the Met and all this.
当然，莉莉的孩子们都是伟大的视觉艺术家，他们将在大都会艺术博物馆展出。
And what was it, Chocolate Pancakes, versus crypto, yeah, I really like that stuff.
那是什么，巧克力煎饼，与加密货币，是的，我真的很喜欢那个东西。
And it is, it's so human, right?
确实如此，这太人性化了，对吧？
You just start picturing a life.
你刚刚开始想象生活。
There's, they did everything you're not supposed to do.
是的，他们做了你不应该做的一切。
You, you start getting way too excited about the very first place you see.
你，你开始对你看到的第一个地方感到太兴奋。
You don't do much research and it felt very human to me.
你没有做太多研究，但对我来说这感觉很人性化。
I feel like I've done this.
我感觉我已经做到了这一点。
Yeah.
是的。
I know people who like you buy a place, but you only saw it during the day.
我知道像你这样的人会买房，但你只在白天看到过。
And you didn't realize there was like a club.
你没有意识到这里就像一个俱乐部。
Yeah, underneath it or something.
是的，在它下面什么的。
at night.
晚上。
Or it's by the train, like you don't reel.
或者是坐火车，就像你不晕倒一样。
There's so many things especially in New York.
尤其是在纽约，有很多事情。
You've got to go there and you have to find a way to go there at night.
你必须去那里，而且你必须想办法在晚上去那里。
They do none of the right things.
他们没有做任何正确的事情。
And they realize they were also scammed by the realtor who was only showing the apartment on the weekend when the sewage treatment plant wasn't operational, which they were seduced in by her.
他们意识到他们也被房地产经纪人骗了，她只在污水处理厂不运行的周末展示公寓，他们是被她引诱进去的。
We bought a place in Brooklyn right across from this elementary school, which is fantastic because you know, you hear kids playing during the day, which is fine, really sweet, but also it's not too tall, so we get good light in through all of those.
我们在布鲁克林买了一个地方，就在这所小学对面，这太棒了，因为你知道，你可以听到孩子们白天玩耍，这很好，真的很甜蜜，但它也不太高，所以我们可以通过所有这些获得良好的光线。
And also like, it's like a school, right?
而且，它就像一所学校，对吧？
Like it's a quiet block.
就像这是一个安静的街区。
It's gonna be quiet at night.
晚上会很安静。
Yeah.
是的。
But now they started doing renovations on this school.
但现在他们开始对这所学校进行翻修。
I mean, the whole thing is covered in scaffolding and they only work on the weekends in the evening now.
我的意思是，整个建筑都被脚手架覆盖，他们现在只在周末晚上工作。
I like, I can hear them working on this school right now.
我喜欢，我现在能听到他们在这所学校工作。
There's no way you could have predicted that though.
但你不可能预测到这一点。
No, no.
不，不。
You just got fucked.
你刚刚被操了。
We lived here for two years before they started doing this renovation of this school.
在他们开始对这所学校进行翻修之前，我们在这里住了两年。
That's really funny.
这真的很有趣。
It's massive.
它是巨大的。
Yeah.
是的。
Maggie Wheeler, Alec.
玛吉·惠勒、亚历克.
Is that Maggie Wheeler?
那是玛吉·惠勒吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Who was on Friends was hilarious is Janice on Friends.
《老友记》中最搞笑的是《老友记》中的珍妮丝。
Yeah.
是的。
She's very.
她很.
And went to Wesley and I think, right, Alec?
然后去了韦斯利，我想，对吧，亚历克？
Yeah.
是的。
That's what you were saying.
这就是你所说的。
I read your mind.
我读懂了你的心思。
See, we still got it, buddy.
看，我们还是明白了，伙计。
Maggie Wheeler, a couple of years ago, I went to see Bonnie Light Horseman.
玛吉·惠勒，几年前，我去看了邦妮·轻骑兵。
Do you know that band?
你认识那个乐队吗？
They're a great band.
他们是一支很棒的乐队。
No.
不。
Yeah.
是的。
Great band.
很棒的乐队。
And I saw her.
我看到了她。
She tapped me on the shoulder and she reintroduced herself.
她拍了拍我的肩膀，重新介绍了自己。
Oh, that's really funny.
哦，这真的很有趣。
She's really sweet.
她真的很可爱。
Yeah, she's great.
是的，她很棒。
When she was a good realtor, because you did sense that there were ice in those veins, and she did totally mislead Marshall and Lily.
当她是一名优秀的房地产经纪人时，因为你确实感觉到那些血管里有冰，她确实完全误导了马歇尔和莉莉。
I will say, long after this episode, and yeah, this is a little bit jumping ahead, later you realize that not only does it smell like sewage treatment, this neighborhood dough with the triplet downwind of the sewage treatment plant, you also learn in a later episode that the whole apartment is like on a slant and the chit just rolls across the apartment.
我会说，在这一集之后很久，是的，这有点超前了，后来你意识到它不仅闻起来像污水处理厂，这个邻居面团与污水处理厂顺风的三重奏，你还在后面的剧集中了解到整个公寓就像是倾斜的，纸条只是滚过公寓。
I, we, after how much mother ended, we bought a place in Tribeca.
我，我们，在妈妈结束了多少年后，我们在翠贝卡买了一个地方。
I still live in this place in Tribeca, another New York neighborhood triangle below Canal, Tribeca, Daoistatripla.
我仍然住在翠贝卡这个地方，这是纽约的另一个三角区，位于运河、翠贝卡、Daoistatripla 下方。
That's what we're playing off of in addition to, no man in Dumbo and all the things, but I bought this apartment and realized many months in living here that the floor was incredibly slanted because I bought like, I bought a desk chair for my wife who did a desk chair and I think this is not a very romantic gift, but I for some shitty gift and for some holiday, I bought her a desk chair with like rolling wheels on it showing them around.
这就是我们所玩的，除了《小飞象》中没有男人和所有的东西，但我买了这套公寓，并意识到住在这里的几个月里，地板非常倾斜，因为我买了类似的东西，我给我的妻子买了一张办公椅，她做了一张办公椅，我认为这不是一个非常浪漫的礼物，但我为了一些糟糕的礼物和一些假期，给她买了一张办公椅，上面有滚轮，让他们到处走走。
And we needed to trade it out because the chair would just roll across the floor like a ghost chair on its own.
我们需要把它换掉，因为椅子会像幽灵椅子一样在地板上滚动。
And I was like, we're leaving Marshall in the least thing years after we'd wrote it.
我当时想，在我们写完这本书几年后，我们就要离开马歇尔了。
It's like, this is after how much mother ended and I'm still, I still live in that apartment.
就好像，母亲去世了多少年后，我仍然住在那间公寓里。
It's a good apartment, but shit will roll across the floor in certain rooms.
这是一套不错的公寓，但在某些房间里，粪便会滚到地板上。
It's like a hundred, something years old.
就像一百岁一样。
It's an old school Tribeca, like, you know, lofty kind of building and used to be storage.
这是一座古老的翠贝卡学校，就像，你知道的，一种高大的建筑，曾经是仓库。
I feel like this connection to the Stowess Retripla episode, because I do love living in Tribeca.
我觉得这与斯托维斯 Retripla 剧集有联系，因为我确实喜欢住在翠贝卡。
I do love my apartment.
我真的很喜欢我的公寓。
We've lived here the entire time since him, you met it.
自从你遇见他以来我们就一直住在这里。
But we're always discovering new fucked up things in our apartment.
但我们总是在公寓里发现新的乱七八糟的东西。
And we didn't robustly, we were shopping for it from LA during the final season of amateur mother and just not able to really do the research, not able to come at night, not able to do all the things.
我们没有坚定地，我们在业余母亲的最后一季期间从洛杉矶​​购买它，只是无法真正进行研究，无法晚上来，无法做所有的事情。
And you're just, it's such a leap of faith.
你只是，这是一次信仰的飞跃。
It is such a big deal.
这是一件大事。
You're pouring a lot of money into this thing.
你在这件事上投入了很多钱。
Marshally, do not have this amount of money.
马歇尔，没有这么多钱。
And it's such a vulnerable act.
这是一种非常脆弱的行为。
And to go and complete that act and sign on the dotted line and then realize how badly you fucked it up is, it's very visceral at the end of that episode.
然后去完成那个动作并在虚线上签名，然后意识到你搞砸了有多么糟糕，这一集的结尾是非常发自内心的。
I think everyone can relate to that moment.
我想每个人都能体会到那一刻。
Like, did I just blow it in this huge way?
就像，我刚刚把它吹得这么厉害吗？
We're gonna be locked here for years.
我们会被锁在这里很多年。
Anyway, it's very, it's stressful, but I think we captured the reality of buying a place.
不管怎样，压力很大，但我认为我们抓住了买房的现实。
Did you know, do you know the neighborhood Guwanis in Brooklyn?
你知道吗，你知道布鲁克林的古瓦尼斯街区吗？
Yeah.
是的。
So I just looked this up to make sure that I have it.
所以我只是查了一下以确保我拥有它。
And this is just, this is just a Google search.
这只是，这只是谷歌搜索。
The Guwanis Canal in Brooklyn is a highly contaminated EPA superfund site.
布鲁克林的古瓦尼斯运河是美国环保局超级基金所在地，污染严重。
Decades of industrial activity have left behind how is this pollutants, including coal tar and PCBs that are known to cause cancer, residents have raised significant concerns about cancerous and high levels of toxic carcinogenic vapors leaking into nearby buildings.
数十年的工业活动留下了这些污染物的痕迹，其中包括已知会致癌的煤焦油和多氯联苯，居民们对泄漏到附近建筑物中的致癌和高浓度的有毒致癌蒸气表示严重担忧。
And I think for a time, Gowanus became like a very hit place to live because they were discounting it quite a bit.
我认为，有一段时间，戈瓦努斯成为了一个非常受欢迎的居住地，因为他们给了很大的折扣。
Yes, stuff came out.
是的，东西出来了。
Yeah, totally.
是的，完全可以。
Yeah, definitely.
是的，绝对是。
It really ain't exploded.
确实没有爆炸。
I feel like it exploded because people can actually afford to be there.
我觉得它爆炸了，因为人们实际上负担得起那里的费用。
It's great, it's great.
太棒了，太棒了。
There's great whole foods that I go to there.
我去那里有很棒的天然食品。
I've been to that Whole Foods many times when visiting Brooklyn and visiting my relatives there.
当我访问布鲁克林和拜访那里的亲戚时，我去过那家全食超市很多次。
And they've cleaned up that canal in a huge way.
他们已经大规模地清理了那条运河。
I think it's way better and I'm sure now no one can afford an apartment there anymore.
我认为那里好多了，我确信现在没有人能买得起那里的公寓了。
No, it's super nice now.
不，现在超级好。
But at the time it was like, artists were pouring in because they're like, hey, there's good rent here.
但当时，艺术家们纷纷涌入，因为他们说，嘿，这里的租金不错。
But I also think that New York, there's different ways to tell stories in New York.
但我也认为纽约有不同的方式来讲述纽约的故事。
Like you can do a kind of rom-com Upper West Side, no gum on the sidewalk, kind of like sheen to things.
就像你可以拍一部上西区的浪漫喜剧，人行道上没有口香糖，有点像东西的光泽。
Or you can do like a little more of like a low-ree side, like what I was trying to do in my first film, Happy Thank You More, please, was like, I literally said in my Sim Talk, for like, I want to feel the gum on the sidewalks.
或者你可以做更多一点像低稀土侧，就像我在我的第一部电影中试图做的那样，请快乐，谢谢你，就像，我在我的模拟谈话中字面意思说，就像，我想感受人行道上的口香糖。
Like, I want to feel the kind of like below 14th Street prime of the whole thing.
就像，我想要感受 14 街黄金地段的那种感觉。
And I think that, how I made my mother, even though it was like kind of glossy and well lit, you guys from the writer's perspective, were really interested in like the cock-a-mouse and Joey Satripla and the things about New York crying on the subway, the things about New York that really are very specific, that, you know, one thing, you know, my wife is a native New Yorker, she grew up on the Upper East Side, and she's really delighting, this is her first time watching it, as our listeners know, but she's really delighting in the super specific New Yorkiness of it all, but the thing that I think you guys do is it both winks to native New Yorkers or people who live here.
我认为，我是如何塑造我的母亲的，尽管它有点光鲜亮丽，从作家的角度来看，你们真的很感兴趣，比如公鸡老鼠和乔伊·萨特里普拉以及纽约在地铁上哭泣的事情，关于纽约的事情非常具体，那，你知道，有一件事，你知道，我的妻子是土生土长的纽约人，她在上东区长大，她真的很高兴，这是她第一次观看正如我们的听众所知，但她真的很喜欢这一切的超级具体的纽约风情，但我认为你们所做的事情是它既向纽约本地人或住在这里的人眨眼。
And says, you know what we're talking about, right?
并说，你知道我们在说什么，对吧？
But if you don't live here, let's say you live in Austria, where the lovely letter came from, it makes you feel like you know New York, or that it gives you like trade secrets, like a little bit of insider knowledge about New York.
但如果你不住在这里，假设你住在奥地利，这封可爱的信就是从那里发出的，它会让你感觉你了解纽约，或者它给你商业秘密，比如一些关于纽约的内幕知识。
And I also like, it makes it this organic living character out of New York.
我也喜欢，它使它成为纽约之外的有机生活特征。
It feels very like Harry Potter worlds, like Diagon Alley, like Doha Satripla, Like, there's always gonna be some new part of this that you haven't found yet.
感觉很像哈利波特的世界，像对角巷，像多哈萨特里普拉，就像，总会有一些你还没有发现的新部分。
It's a little bit magical.
这有点神奇。
Maybe it's bad magic sometimes, but there's magic in it somehow.
也许有时候魔法很糟糕，但无论如何它还是有魔法的。
And also the local characters that populate.
还有当地的人物。
The thing about New York, and we've talked about this, but like, we live in this area of Brooklyn that's just like a couple square blocks with a park, right?
关于纽约的事情，我们已经讨论过这个，但是，我们住在布鲁克林的这个地区，就像几个带有公园的街区，对吧？
Like, it's beautiful, but it's like, it is a neighborhood.
就像，它很漂亮，但它就像，这是一个社区。
Like, I see that we go on a walk every morning.
就像，我看到我们每天早上都去散步。
We see the same people, you know?
我们看到的是同一个人，你知道吗？
Yeah, totally.
是的，完全可以。
I do think that there are these, you know, even like seeing Moripovitch, like there's just these little wings of New York City-ness that you guys did and threaded throughout.
我确实认为有这些，你知道，甚至就像看到莫里波维奇一样，就像你们所做的并贯穿始终的纽约市的这些小翅膀一样。
I think it's very satisfying, whether you live here or don't.
我觉得无论你住在这里还是不住这里，都很满意。
Yeah, I know, totally.
是的，我完全知道。
I really like, I really like the idea that there's always gonna be some neighborhood you never heard of and some newly created idea.
我真的很喜欢，我真的很喜欢这样的想法：总会有一些你从未听说过的社区和一些新创造的想法。
You don't know exactly where this is, like you see the bridge, a bridge out the window of Doha, Citriplum, like maybe it's like, that's the bridge, like that's on the east side and they're like, Roosevelt Island is out the window or something.
你不知道它到底在哪里，就像你看到那座桥，多哈窗外的一座桥，Citriplum，就像，那是桥，就像那座桥在东边，他们就像，罗斯福岛就在窗外什么的。
But we do it.
但我们做到了。
It's very unclear exactly where no issue people is.
目前还不清楚哪里没有问题。
Not long ago, my wife and I, for many years, we had to commute back and forth from Tribeca to the Upper West Side because there's so much school in the Upper West Side.
不久前，我和妻子多年来不得不往返于翠贝卡和上西区，因为上西区有很多学校。
And there's this little pocket on the West Side highway.
西区高速公路上有一个小口袋。
Some New Yorkers will know what I'm talking about that was right past a sewage treatment plant.
一些纽约人会知道我在说什么，那是在污水处理厂旁边。
And it smells like shit.
而且闻起来像屎一样。
Every so often, you just catch the right day and the right moment.
很多时候，你只是抓住了正确的日子和正确的时刻。
It smells fucking terrible.
闻起来真他妈难闻。
And we would sometimes walk that whole length.
有时我们会走完全程。
You can go drop off or we drop off our son and the upper side and then walk it back to try back a like huge long lock.
你可以去下车，或者我们把我们的儿子和上边放下，然后走回来尝试返回一个像巨大的长锁。
It's like takes two hours and we walk past that.
好像需要两个小时，然后我们就过去了。
And my wife at one point was like, oh my God, is this dough is a tree play?
我的妻子有一次就想，天哪，这个面团是树上玩的吗？
Is this what you were writing about?
这是你写的吗？
I was like, no, we don't know where dough is a tree play is.
我当时想，不，我们不知道面团在哪里，树上的游戏在哪里。
But in this great way, it's just like this magical, it really feels like Harry Potter world.
但以这种伟大的方式，它就像这样神奇，真的感觉就像哈利波特的世界。
Like it's just this pocket of London.
就好像这只是伦敦的这个街区。
And you go back to the next day and it's not there.
当你回到第二天，它就不在那里了。
It's not there anymore.
它已经不在那里了。
It moves around the city.
它在城市周围移动。
And I feel like I love that vibe on this show.
我觉得我喜欢这个节目的氛围。
We created this universe.
我们创造了这个宇宙。
It's a little bit magic and weird.
这有点神奇和奇怪。
I don't know where it goes.
我不知道它去哪儿了。
The triple is, but it's somewhere.
三重是，但它在某个地方。
And I was like, essentially this, I said to her, this isn't what we thought of.
我对她说，基本上是这样的，这不是我们想到的。
I don't think this place smelled this way.
我不认为这个地方有这种味道。
And our 20s, when we lived here, this is a newer sewage treatment plant that has been set up, I believe.
而我们20多岁的时候，当我们住在这里时，我相信这是一个较新的污水处理厂已经建立起来了。
But I was like, this might as well be it.
但我想，这也可能是这样。
This is the observation that was at work and it really does exist.
这是正在发挥作用的观察结果，而且确实存在。
You know, I'll have to fact check this with Jordana to make sure, but I'm 99% certain that her older half brother, his mother remarried a guy who was the guy who named Dumbo.
你知道，我得和乔丹娜核实一下才能确定，但​​我 99% 确定她同父异母的哥哥，他的母亲再婚了一个叫小飞象的人。
That's crazy.
太疯狂了。
That's so crazy because I was also just thinking like it was not called Dumbo when I lived here in my 20s.
这太疯狂了，因为当我 20 多岁时住在这里时，我也只是想它不叫 Dumbo。
No one referred to it that way.
没有人这样提到它。
And that's what we're saying that there's always going to be some new down under the Manhattan Bridge overpass, right?
这就是我们所说的曼哈顿大桥立交桥下总会有一些新的东西，对吗？
Yep.
是的。
That's it.
就是这样。
Yeah, there's always going to be that.
是的，总会有这样的事。
There will always be, it's a city of constant reinvention.
永远都会有，这是一座不断革新的城市。
And it like, I'm not, maybe it's not called there was a cheap look in future Ted's world in 2030.
就像，我不是，也许这不叫 2030 年未来泰德的世界看起来很廉价。
Maybe it's not called that anymore.
也许不再这么叫了。
But at that moment, it was just the new term.
但在那一刻，这只是一个新术语。
No one knew what it meant.
没有人知道这意味着什么。
But they were too afraid and embarrassed to admit.
但他们太害怕、太尴尬，不敢承认。
When I first heard Dumbo, I was living in LA.
当我第一次听到 Dumbo 时，我住在洛杉矶。
People started calling it Dumbo while in LA.
人们在洛杉矶时开始称其为 Dumbo。
And I was like, what is that?
我当时想，那是什么？
I think it was called Dumbo long before you realized.
我想在你意识到之前它就被称为小飞象了。
It's called Dumbo, yeah.
它叫小飞象，是的。
it.
它。
I never heard it in my whole life and living in my 20s New York.
我二十多岁的时候住在纽约，这辈子都没听过这句话。
I feel like I never heard that term.
我感觉我从来没有听说过这个词。
There's just so great.
真是太棒了。
It's so New York that no lead up like just the thing.
这就是纽约，没有任何线索。
Yeah.
是的。
So no lead done by it's all these things.
所以所有这些事情都没有起到任何作用。
Yeah.
是的。
So we knew we wanted to do a play on that.
所以我们知道我们想以此为基础进行表演。
And I think this is very much a Carter Bayes invention downwind.
我认为这很大程度上是卡特贝叶斯的顺风发明。
Downwind is a sewage treatment plan.
顺风处是污水处理方案。
This is some Carter Bayes brilliance because Carter He loves New York City, he's from Cleveland, he's an outsider, but he fell in love with New York.
这是卡特·贝叶斯的一些才华，因为卡特热爱纽约市，他来自克利夫兰，他是一个局外人，但他爱上了纽约。
He always loved this exact thing we're talking about of like the mythology of New York.
他一直很喜欢我们正在谈论的纽约神话。
We literally wrote a pilot years later after how much of a mother called New York Mythological that plays with that idea of an actually magic New York City that failed the pilots out there.
几年后，我们确实写了一个试播集，因为有一位名叫《纽约神话》的母亲，玩弄了一个真正神奇的纽约市的想法，但让那里的试播集失败了。
It was fun.
很有趣。
It's like a Buffy kind of New York thing.
这就像纽约的巴菲那样。
And it was again just diving even deeper into that feeling of like New York is a ever-shifting magical place that can't quite be explained logically.
这再次让我更加深入地感受到纽约是一个不断变化的神奇地方，无法完全用逻辑来解释。
That pilot was taken by a great podcast called Dead Pilots Society, and a table read was organized for it.
那个飞行员是由一个名为“死亡飞行员协会”的伟大播客拍摄的，并为其组织了一个表阅读。
This is like a month or two, a couple months ago, and it exists on Dead Pilots Society, and we're gonna drop it into our feet.
这就像一两个月，几个月前，它存在于《死亡飞行员协会》中，我们要把它放在我们的脚下。
It's called New York Mythological.
它的名字叫《纽约神话》。
It plays even more with this concept of like the magic of New York.
它更体现了纽约的魔力这一概念。
Like the, and all of them.
就像，以及所有这些。
Who was in it?
谁在里面？
Are there any of the actors that you've worked with before that were in it?
里面有你以前合作过的演员吗？
CalPenn is in the table read for New York.
CalPenn 位于纽约的表格中。
CalPenn, my neighbor.
卡尔彭大学，我的邻居。
Your neighbor.
你的邻居。
I know that because he's also across from the school.
我知道，因为他也在学校对面。
We took him out to dinner to thank him for doing that a few weeks ago because he did that table read for us like a zoom table read.
我们带他出去吃晚饭，感谢他几周前所做的事情，因为他为我们做的表格阅读就像缩放表格阅读一样。
And he revealed that he was your neighbor and he sees you quite frequently proving your point about your neighborhoodiness.
他透露他是你的邻居，他看到你经常证明你的邻里关系的观点。
Yes.
是的。
And one of the people in the solids in our band Becky Lichtenfeld is right around the corner from you and the same neighborhood.
我们乐队贝基·利希滕菲尔德 (Becky Lichtenfeld) 的一位成员就在您和同一个社区的拐角处。
It really is like you live in a little like Sesame Street road.
这真的就像你住在有点像芝麻街的路上。
She's one of the she's one of the local like regulars we see on our walk.
她是我们在散步时看到的当地常客之一。
she says she sees you.
她说她看到你了。
You both have your dogs all the time.
你们俩一直都有自己的狗。
All the time.
一直以来。
And by the way, the dead pilot sighted, that's all, if you're listening to this podcast and you are, it's in here.
顺便说一句，看到死去的飞行员，仅此而已，如果您正在听这个播客并且您正在听，它就在这里。
It's already up.
已经起来了。
It's already on the feet.
已经上脚了
Okay.
好的。
Strolled up.
漫步而上。
So you will, you will, is a funny half hour romantic comedy in a magical tinge, New York.
所以你会的，你会的，是一部有趣的半小时浪漫喜剧，充满魔幻色彩，纽约。
And it's really funny, Cal, Cal Penn plays this guy that has had a curse put on him.
这真的很有趣，卡尔，卡尔·佩恩扮演这个被诅咒的人。
He did wrong one woman who turned out to be a witch.
他冤枉了一名女巫，结果发现她是一名女巫。
is that a curse put on him that every woman in New York thinks they had a one-night stand with him and he never called them.
纽约的每个女人都认为她们与他有一夜情，而他却从未给她们打电话，这对他来说是一种诅咒。
So his life has been going on for years.
所以他的生活已经持续了很多年。
His life has been spent in New York, walking to the street, having women go, fuck you!
他的一生都是在纽约度过的，走在街上，让女人走，操你妈的！
Carl Hobbes, you motherfucker!
卡尔·霍布斯，你这个混蛋！
Like that's been his whole life.
仿佛这就是他的一生。
And the whole episode is, can we figure out how to free this poor man of this?
整个情节是，我们能想出如何让这个可怜的人摆脱困境吗？
He did do one wrong thing.
他确实做错了一件事。
He did hook up and have one, but he was the wrong woman.
他确实勾搭上了一个女人，但他找错了女人。
He scorns the wrong woman who turns out to be a witch who lives on the Upper East Side.
他鄙视了一个错误的女人，结果发现她是一个住在上东区的女巫。
It was basically took the dating and magic of New York and just took it a little bit further than him and was able to.
这基本上就是纽约的约会和魔力，只是比他走得更远一点，并且能够做到。
I wish that one had gone, but it's sold to CBS.
我希望那一个已经消失了，但它被卖给了哥伦比亚广播公司。
We developed it for like half year.
我们开发了它大约半年的时间。
We're going at CBS.
我们要去哥伦比亚广播公司。
We just finished how I met your mother.
我们刚刚讲完我是如何认识你母亲的。
This is going to be on, man.
这将会继续，伙计。
This will be our show we shoot and do in New York.
这将是我们在纽约拍摄和制作的节目。
That did not happen, but it is now available for you as a table re-ident on my Friday.
那并没有发生，但现在您可以在我的周五作为餐桌常驻者。
And this old man, he must admit he fell in love with you, new York City.
而这个老人，他必须承认他爱上了你，纽约市。
And now, commercials!
现在，广告！
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，Hyper-Fixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
诸如此类的问题，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们还解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that caused that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这是来自 Radiotopia 的 Hyper-Fixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts, or at hyperfixedpod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客，或在 hyperfixedpod.com 上都可以找到它。
End of commercials, back to show.
广告结束，回到节目。
I really thought it was funny.
我真的觉得这很有趣。
For some reason, the shot of Ted and Barney just getting loaded on the couch.
由于某种原因，特德和巴尼刚刚在沙发上上床的镜头。
I love, again, it's like Ted is like this single guy of the season.
我再次喜欢泰德就像这个赛季的单身男人。
Ted is in this new, I think Hemington called it a few episodes ago, free-ranged Ted.
泰德在这个新剧中，我想海明顿在几集前称之为“自由放养的泰德”。
Ted is leaning into being single again, and it includes being a shitty roommate to the married couple that has jobs.
泰德又倾向于单身，其中包括成为有工作的已婚夫妇的糟糕室友。
And I really liked him and Barney just being trouble for this married couple.
我真的很喜欢他和巴尼，只是给这对已婚夫妇带来麻烦。
Well, I like the shot of it before the reveal.
嗯，我喜欢揭晓前的镜头。
It was very pleasing to me for some reason, because it was like, it's not Ted and Barney in the bar, it's not them on the prowl, there's no women around.
出于某种原因，这让我很高兴，因为就像，酒吧里没有特德和巴尼，没有他们在徘徊，周围没有女人。
Just hanging out on the couch.
只是在沙发上闲逛。
That feels very real to me in your 20s.
对于20多岁的我来说，这感觉非常真实。
Like, what are we gonna do in right?
就像，我们要做什么？
I don't know, let's each have eight to 10.
我不知道，我们每人有八到十个吧。
Like what?
比如什么？
On your couch?
在你的沙发上吗？
On the couch.
在沙发上。
And go nowhere.
并且无处可去。
You know what it was?
你知道那是什么吗？
And just talk shit, you know.
只是说些废话，你知道的。
What it was a reference to where you cut wide and you see them at Marshall and Lilliard and Trich.
这是指你在哪里切开，你会在马歇尔、利利亚德和特里奇身上看到他们。
Please stop.
请停下来。
It's the bunk bed joke.
这是双层床的笑话。
It's dead in the bunk bed.
它死在双层床上了。
But you've done that a couple of times in the first couple of seasons.
但在前几个赛季中你已经这样做过几次了。
You should come, there should be a name for that kind of reveal.
你应该来，这种揭露应该有一个名字。
It's like a pop wide kind of reveal that.
这就像一种流行的揭示。
Very jarring, wide cut, totally different angle.
非常刺耳，宽切，完全不同的角度。
We're just in a different movie.
我们只是在不同的电影里。
I really liked that they had candle-like dinner going, and Barney and Dad have just been talking about boobs, literally just talking about the assuming motorboats.
我真的很喜欢他们有蜡烛般的晚餐，巴尼和爸爸刚刚在谈论胸部，实际上只是在谈论假设的摩托艇。
And I really liked that speed for Ted, because he's just a fucking dude, and he's a dude in his 20s still.
我真的很喜欢 Ted 的速度，因为他就是个该死的家伙，而且他还是个 20 多岁的家伙。
He has these high-minded aspirations, but he's 29.
他有这些崇高的抱负，但他才 29 岁。
You remember when I said on Sweet Taste of Liberty, I wish I had been like a touch more amused by Barney.
你还记得当我在《自由的甜蜜滋味》中说过时，我希望巴尼能更逗乐我一点。
Yeah.
是的。
Like I wish I had played it less like You're there here.
就像我希望我没有像《你在这里》那样演奏。
Star shirt, eye rolling.
明星衬衫，翻白眼。
I think I was playing it a little like Steve Martin to John Candy.
我想我的演奏有点像史蒂夫·马丁对约翰·坎迪的演奏。
Yeah.
是的。
In playing Strains and Automobiles.
在玩《应变和汽车》时。
Totally.
完全。
That's kind of the energy I was playing.
这就是我所发挥的能量。
Yeah.
是的。
And I kind of wish I had played it.
我有点希望我玩过它。
Like I had a little more of this couch energy, which is like, look, this guy's insane, but it does lead to great stories.
就像我有更多的沙发能量一样，就像，看，这家伙疯了，但它确实带来了很棒的故事。
They need each other.
他们需要彼此。
Season two ended with their recommitment ceremony to each other as wingmen.
第二季以他们作为僚机的重新承诺仪式结束。
And we've carried that into season three in this great way.
我们以这种很棒的方式将这一点带入了第三季。
The only thing missing for me in season three so far was really acknowledging that there's this married couple living with a single guy, looking at their future.
到目前为止，我在第三季中唯一缺少的就是真正承认这对已婚夫妇与一个单身男人住在一起，展望他们的未来。
And we didn't really talk about that the first few episodes.
在前几集中我们并没有真正讨论过这个问题。
And I really like these past two episodes that I think Josh, you're right, it plays like a two-parter.
我真的很喜欢过去的两集，我认为乔什，你是对的，它就像一个两部分一样。
This huge problem, this marital problem, this newly married couple, huge debt, buying an apartment, Lily has a secret.
这个巨大的问题，这个婚姻问题，这对新婚夫妇，巨额债务，购买公寓，莉莉有一个秘密。
And by the way, are we gonna live with a single dude forever who's gonna be talking about boobs on the couch.
顺便说一句，我们会永远和一个在沙发上谈论胸部的单身男人住在一起吗？
Like, they have entered these different life chapters, which essentially how I met your mother at its core is married guy and his best friend is in a very committed couple, many steps ahead of him.
就像，他们已经进入了这些不同的人生篇章，本质上我是如何认识你母亲的，其核心是已婚男人，而他最好的朋友是一对非常忠诚的夫妇，比他领先了很多步。
And how do those two, how do those people all stay close when they're in completely different movies from each other?
当这两个人在彼此完全不同的电影中时，他们如何保持亲密关系？
Like Ted and Barney on that couch, Marshall Milly at that candle at dinner 10 feet away, they're just in different chapters.
就像泰德和巴尼在沙发上，马歇尔·米莉在 10 英尺外晚餐时在蜡烛旁一样，他们只是处于不同的章节。
They're different life chapters.
他们是不同的人生篇章。
Like, they're in, they're in porkies.
就像，他们在，他们在猪肉里。
Yeah, you know, they're still there.
是的，你知道，他们还在那里。
And Marcia and Lillie are in this like adult sophisticated, like romantic comedy.
玛西娅和莉莉在这部电影中表现得像成人般精致，像浪漫喜剧。
Or attempting to, to do that.
或者试图这样做。
They're attempting to move, they're trying to grow up.
他们在努力前进，他们在努力成长。
And that's what I like so much about Lillie's secret that predates this huge, this new like mature chapter.
这就是我非常喜欢莉莉的秘密的原因，它早于这个巨大的、新的、成熟的章节。
She's carrying this burden of the secret in that we, we the audience didn't know about, no one knew about, Robin didn't know about.
她背负着这个秘密的重担，我们，我们观众不知道，没有人知道，罗宾也不知道。
And we just learned this huge thing that's just like this albatross.
我们刚刚了解到这个巨大的东西，就像这只信天翁一样。
And I like that.
我喜欢这样。
I like watching them try to climb up into adult life and there's this thing holding them back.
我喜欢看他们试图爬入成年生活，但有一种东西阻碍了他们。
I really like that.
我真的很喜欢这样。
And I like the mystery of what was this fight.
我喜欢这场战斗的神秘性。
I love that Ted, Ted is actually good at being an detective until he gets it entirely wrong when the fight was about.
我喜欢泰德，泰德实际上很擅长当侦探，直到战斗即将开始时他完全错了。
But until that point he's quite good.
但在那之前他的表现都非常好。
I loved the, I remember, there's certain things you just remember.
我喜欢，我记得，有些事情你只记得。
Sometimes you remember when you guys gave me something.
有时你会记得你们给了我一些东西。
I'm switching from the first to the second person, But when you guys would give me something that I remember that little bit where she walks in on Ted shaving, and I remember the crew really delighted in that, especially like sea camera.
我正在从第一人称切换到第二人称，但是当你们给我一些东西时，我记得她走进泰德剃须的那一刻，我记得工作人员对此非常高兴，尤其是像海洋相机。
I think Bruce and his gang really thought that was funny.
我认为布鲁斯和他的帮派真的认为这很有趣。
But I thought you were shaving, well, I thought you were shaving your face.
但我以为你在刮胡子，好吧，我以为你在刮脸。
What was it?
那是什么？
Well, clearly I wasn't.
嗯，显然我不是。
Yeah, yeah, clearly I wasn't.
是的，是的，显然我不是。
It was so that was the hardest laugh for Rebecca sitting on the couch next to me watching that that was a really really funny Moment yeah, I really like that little case study and like single guy living with the married couple They are married now and it's and it they're just they're quick.
丽贝卡坐在我旁边的沙发上，看着那真是一个非常有趣的时刻，是的，我真的很喜欢这个小案例研究，就像单身汉和已婚夫妇住在一起一样，他们现在结婚了，他们只是很快就结婚了。
They're they're like quick Hirschfeld blinds.
它们就像快速的赫希菲尔德百叶窗。
They're just quick.
他们只是很快。
Yes quickly sketches.
是的，快速绘制草图。
Yeah, they're little sketches that really put it in high relief Like this is the problem.
是的，它们是一些小草图，真正把它放在高浮雕上，就像这就是问题所在。
Yeah, also Also, Jordana made me rewind and freeze on my face when Marshall comes out with a peanut butter.
是的，还有，当马歇尔拿出花生酱时，乔丹娜让我倒带并冻结在我的脸上。
And she was like, that's the face you make when I say like, why did you do the, where did you put the, or whatever, like, you know, like a marital thing of like.
她就像，当我说，你为什么这么做，你把这个放在哪里，或者诸如此类的事情时，你就会做出这样的表情。
The slightly busted face?
脸有点破？
Like a slightly busted face.
就像一张稍微破了的脸。
That's exactly right.
完全正确。
She's like, I know they're nasty names so well.
她说，我很清楚他们的名字很讨厌。
She had to rewind it.
她不得不倒带。
But it turned out to be Lily.
但结果却是莉莉。
It was Lily did it anyway.
反正都是莉莉干的。
It was an effect, but it was, it was a mystery of busted face.
这是一种效果，但确实是，这是一张破脸的谜团。
The martial speech about the real world is so funny.
关于现实世界的武术演讲是如此有趣。
Yeah, not the early seasons.
是的，不是前几季。
Not the early seasons when they had jobs.
不是他们有工作的早期。
I'm talking about Hawaii and Africa.
我说的是夏威夷和非洲。
I watched so many of those early real world seasons in Sotomayor.
我在索托马约尔看了很多现实世界的早期剧集。
We were pretty religious about those.
我们对这些非常虔诚。
So that was the bad thing for me.
所以这对我来说是件坏事。
Well, how great that you had an outlet to talk about them.
好吧，你有一个谈论它们的机会真是太好了。
Yes, and add it up to something.
是的，并将其添加到某些东西中。
Ben Lee, my songwriting friend who I had the band with Radner and Lee, he posted this thing on Instagram that made me laugh so hard where he was at Largo doing some evening and he was talking to Judd Apatow backstage about the Real Housewives franchise.
本·李 (Ben Lee) 是我的歌曲创作朋友，我与拉德纳 (Radner) 和李 (Lee) 组建了乐队，他在 Instagram 上发布了这件事，这让我笑得很厉害，当时他在 Largo 做事，当时他正在后台与贾德·阿帕图 (Judd Apatow) 谈论《真正的家庭主妇》系列。
And Ben like knew two of them very specifically and very well.
本对他们中的两个人非常了解。
And he said Judd knew all of them like perfectly.
他说贾德对他们所有人都很了解。
Like he had not met a single one.
就好像他一个人都没见过一样。
How does he find the time?
他如何找到时间？
And Ben said, Ben said, I don't think I would have the time or the energy to keep up with all that.
本说，本说，我认为我没有时间或精力来跟上这一切。
And Judd said, you can do it.
贾德说，你能做到。
You have to just do it.
你必须这么做。
You can find the time.
你可以找时间。
This is important for you.
这对你来说很重要。
You have the time and you can do it.
你有时间并且可以做到。
And he said it was like this weird showbiz pep talk.
他说这就像演艺圈奇怪的鼓舞人心的谈话。
That's really funny.
这真的很有趣。
This is important.
这很重要。
You got to get honest.
你必须诚实。
That's amazing.
太棒了。
I really liked Barney's immediate deference to Ted.
我真的很喜欢巴尼对特德的立即尊重。
Once Ted started being really confident as the detective Ted in that act three, like figuring out what this fight was, Barney just wants a strong male role model in his life.
一旦泰德开始真正自信地扮演第三幕中的侦探泰德，就像弄清楚这场战斗是什么，巴尼只想在他的生活中找到一个强大的男性榜样。
And the second Ted starts being really strong and clear, Barney's like, yeah, yeah boss.
第二个泰德开始变得非常坚强和清晰，巴尼就像，是的，是的，老板。
And like sneering at Robin, like don't get in Ted's way, like energy, like Ted's like cracking the case.
就像嘲笑罗宾，就像不要妨碍泰德，就像能量，就像泰德破案一样。
He's just absolutely embracing second in command.
他完全接受了第二把手的位置。
And then you're right, in that transition, once they think Marshall Lee might be getting a divorce, Barney falls the fuck apart.
然后你是对的，在这个转变中，一旦他们认为马歇尔·李可能要离婚，巴尼就崩溃了。
And I thought he wanted Ted to be his strong male role model as the detective.
我认为他希望泰德成为他作为侦探的强有力的男性榜样。
And then he also wants these parent figures.
然后他也想要这些父母的形象。
And I guess some hope of couplehood that he gets out of Marshall and Lilly.
我猜想他从马歇尔和莉莉那里得到了一些夫妻关系的希望。
He crumbles so fucking hard when he had the thought of Marshall and Lilly potentially breaking up.
当他想到马歇尔和莉莉可能会分手时，他崩溃得非常厉害。
And I think that was so winning and charming and vulnerable that it kind of did.
我认为这是如此迷人、如此迷人、如此脆弱，以至于它确实做到了。
in the way you described earlier, it kind of did make it right how horrible he was to poor April Bulby earlier in the episode.
就像你之前描述的那样，这确实让我们明白了他在这一集早些时候对可怜的阿普丽尔·布尔比有多么可怕。
But I do, I think he probably did deserve a little, a little like something, a little swat, a little slap, karmically and more than he got in this one, because he was pretty straighty the way he walked out on her in the shower.
但我确实，我认为他可能确实应该受到一点，一点像什么，一点打击，一点耳光，业力上的，比他在这一次得到的更多，因为他在淋浴时从她身上走出来的方式非常直率。
You know that?
你知道吗？
It was funny.
这很有趣。
I didn't remember what episode it was from, but me wearing sunglasses with Barney saying there's a reason you're, or I think Barney says you, there's a reason your name is Robin.
我不记得那是哪一集了，但我戴着墨镜，巴尼说你是有原因的，或者我认为巴尼说你，你的名字叫罗宾是有原因的。
No, Ted says it to Robin.
不，是特德对罗宾说的。
And this one is Ted says Robin.
罗宾说，这是特德。
Yeah, there's reason you're a reason your name is Robin not that man.
是的，这就是你的名字叫罗宾而不是那个人的原因。
That's like a pretty that That's a meme that goes around to me.
这就像我周围的一个漂亮的模因。
I see that all the time I was like excited to get up to it the in this episode when watching this last day because I was like That's from that meme from that show That's our show.
我发现，当我最后一天观看这一集中的节目时，我一直很兴奋，因为我就像那是来自那个节目的模因，这就是我们的节目。
I Did not remember I you could never I would never I would lose a bet if you asked me what episode that was from I thought it was from later in the series because Ted does play detective Ted a couple times in series.
我不记得我你永远不会我永远不会如果你问我那是哪一集，我会输掉赌注，我以为是该系列的后面几集，因为特德确实在系列中扮演了几次侦探特德。
And I was really like, Oh shit, we're okay.
我真的很想，哦，该死，我们没事。
That's in season three.
那是在第三季。
That meme.
那个模因。
You guys did a lot of like, um, you guys did the CSI kind of forensic, yeah, that parody held.
你们做了很多类似的事情，嗯，你们做了《犯罪现场调查》（CSI）之类的法证，是的，那个戏仿是成立的。
Yeah, they're green.
是的，它们是绿色的。
But also, I didn't know this at the time, but CSI Miami was on and David Caruso would like, he did a lot of sunglasses acting did some sunglasses work.
而且，我当时并不知道这一点，但是 CSI 迈阿密正在播出，大卫·卡鲁索希望，他做了很多墨镜表演，做了一些墨镜工作。
That was his thing.
那是他的事。
And I, I have, you know, over the years, because we were at CBS events and all these things.
我，你知道，这些年来，因为我们参加了哥伦比亚广播公司的活动和所有这些事情。
A couple of those actors from CSI Miami, not David Caruso, by the way, but a couple of them said, we really love that episode.
顺便说一下，《CSI 迈阿密》的几位演员不是大卫·卡鲁索，但他们中的一些人说，我们真的很喜欢这一集。
Like, we really love that.
就像，我们真的很喜欢那样。
Yeah.
是的。
When you guys kind of like parodied us a bit.
当你们有点模仿我们的时候。
Yeah.
是的。
You were, that's what it was.
你本来就是，就是这样。
You were doing Caruso, but I don't even know how aware you were that that's what you were doing in the moment.
你在扮演卡鲁索，但我什至不知道你是否意识到这就是你此刻正在做的事情。
I guess we've probably shown you a tape of it.
我想我们可能已经给你看过一盘磁带了。
No, you either.
不，你也是。
You were Carter had to explain it to me because I forgive me.
你是卡特必须向我解释，因为我原谅了我。
I was not a CSI Miami watcher.
我不是 CSI 迈阿密的观察者。
But I suppose you watched every episode actually.
但我想你实际上看过每一集。
Dave Baker or someone pulled a clip for me.
戴夫·贝克（Dave Baker）或其他人帮我拉了一个夹子。
Like someone showed me.
就像有人向我展示的那样。
And if you've seen one, you've seen him all, he did his trademark thing, but you did it, you nailed it.
如果你见过一个人，你就见过他的全部，他做了他标志性的事情，但你做到了，你做到了。
Detective Ted was excellent in this episode.
泰德侦探在这一集中表现出色。
It was very, that full run was so fucking funny.
这真是非常非常有趣。
And just Barney being so all in on it was just hilarious.
巴尼如此投入，真是太搞笑了。
He just immediately deferred to Ted.
他立即听从了特德的指示。
The Mosby boys cracked a lot of big cases.
莫斯比兄弟破获了很多大案。
The case of the missing retainer, was that the one?
侍从失踪案，就是这个吗？
Yes, let me guess I was in the garbage.
是的，让我猜猜我在垃圾堆里。
Why are you like this?
你为什么这样？
And Barney hates that Robin's ruining it.
巴尼讨厌罗宾毁了它。
Barney really likes Detective Ted.
巴尼真的很喜欢泰德侦探。
It's just such a leap.
这只是一个飞跃。
I'm such a little kid.
我真是个小孩子。
Dude, you're gonna need a stronger stomach than that, Delphi.
伙计，你需要比这更强大的胃，德尔菲。
Delphi is just film noir immediately.
德尔福立刻就变成了黑色电影。
It was great, yeah.
太棒了，是的。
But also, I mean, his lifting up the...
而且，我的意思是，他举起...
I mean, yeah, he's a good detective until he has the absolute wrong conclusion.
我的意思是，是的，他是一个好侦探，直到他得出绝对错误的结论。
He just has the wrong conclusion, But he's really close.
他只是得出了错误的结论，但他确实很接近。
He really, he almost threaded the needle and then not quite.
他真的，他几乎穿针引线，然后又没有完全穿针。
Um, but it's a good, there's something also funny about arrogant Ted is like, I mean, certainly there's a lot of arrogant Ted is coming down the bike, but I think you guys were finding a different speed for him where he was just, just, just kind of overconfident in his, uh, yes, yeah, and smart.
嗯，但这很好，傲慢的特德也有一些有趣的地方，我的意思是，当然有很多傲慢的特德从自行车上下来，但我认为你们正在为他找到不同的速度，他只是，只是，对他的，呃，是的，是的，和聪明有点过于自信。
Well, like we talked about, uh, out of my case thing, nothing funnier than being confidently wrong.
好吧，就像我们谈到的，呃，就我个人而言，没有什么比自信地犯错更有趣的了。
There is nothing funnier and when Ted ends up having the right conclusion, it's funny.
没有什么比这更有趣的了，当泰德最终得出正确的结论时，这很有趣。
But up until that moment, he was actually really good.
但直到那一刻之前，他实际上真的很好。
I like when Robin does pitch in one thing she noticed, and he's like, nice catch, Rook.
我喜欢当罗宾投出她注意到的一件事时，他说，接球不错，鲁克。
You're very funny.
你很有趣。
You were having fun in that whole sequence.
你在整个过程中玩得很开心。
That was a great sequence.
这是一个很棒的序列。
I loved it.
我喜欢它。
I remember loving that.
我记得很喜欢那个。
Yeah.
是的。
That was a delight.
那真是令人高兴。
Like Ted doesn't have a ton in this episode, right?
就像泰德在这一集中没有太多内容一样，对吧？
He's a little bit along for these other rides.
他对其他的游乐设施也有一些了解。
But I think that's such a star turn for Ted in that moment that it kind of makes up for the whole.
但我认为那一刻对特德来说是一个明星转变，它在某种程度上弥补了整体。
Yeah, so that's when you don't have a big episode, you guys would give each character one Aria.
是的，所以当你没有大集的时候，你们会给每个角色一个咏叹调。
One great bit, one Aria, yes.
一个伟大的部分，一个咏叹调，是的。
Yeah, they would just be like, they'd just get to solo for a little while to like.
是的，他们会想，他们只是想独奏一会儿就喜欢了。
And what is meme from this episode?
这一集的模因是什么？
Yeah.
是的。
The Batman Robin line is very, right?
蝙蝠侠罗宾的台词很对吧？
There's a couple other very memorable things from this episode.
这一集中还有其他一些非常令人难忘的事情。
I see the dough is a triple thing, meme it a little bit too, but that moment was the big Ted moment.
我看到面团是三重的东西，也有点模因它，但那一刻是重要的泰德时刻。
I loved seeing a flashback to the reverse Mohawk cutting.
我喜欢看到反向莫霍克发型的闪回。
Yes, as his second stupidest thing, the first one was jumping off the roof as some sort of bird costume.
是的，作为他第二件最愚蠢的事情，第一件事就是穿着某种鸟服装从屋顶跳下来。
Do you know what your Diana said about Marshall and Lily regarding their real estate stuff?
你知道你的戴安娜王妃对马歇尔和莉莉关于他们的房地产的事情说了些什么吗？
She said, I could help them.
她说，我可以帮助他们。
And she said that because she has a side, my wife is one of those street easy Zillow lurkers.
她说，因为她有自己的一面，所以我的妻子是那些街头轻松的 Zillow 潜伏者之一。
Like she's always, you know.
就像她一贯的那样，你知道。
But like Carter, what are you doing?
但像卡特一样，你在做什么？
She's like, nothing.
她就像，什么都没有。
This is Carter street easy.
这是卡特街容易。
Oh, really?
哦真的吗？
This is Carter.
这是卡特。
This is why he loves all this shit.
这就是为什么他喜欢这一切。
He is such a real estate whore, that guy, he really is, he would say the same thing.
他就是这样一个房地产妓女，那个家伙，他确实是，他也会说同样的话。
We have friends who, they'll put your banana on the case, because she's not looking for an apartment for us, but she loves the, it's almost like looking for your friends like we look through the stating site with me.
我们有朋友，他们会把你的香蕉放在案子上，因为她不是在为我们寻找公寓，但她喜欢这样，这几乎就像寻找你的朋友一样，就像我们和我一起浏览声明网站一样。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
Like I'm not looking for me, I'm looking for my friend.
就像我不是在找我自己，我是在找我的朋友。
Yeah, but she has, she knows, she knows how to look at those things and how to see.
是的，但她知道，她知道如何看待这些事情以及如何看待。
Did she lead the way, getting you guys to Fort Green to be calmer than that?
她有没有带路，让你们去格林堡，让自己变得更加平静？
This was weirdly me.
这就是奇怪的我。
This was where you interested?
这是你感兴趣的地方吗？
This was me because she didn't want to leave the neighborhood and we looked at a place kind of like a closer to downtown Brooklyn and we were looking at a rental and I told a woman, oh, we really want to stay in this neighborhood and she said, well, we have a place.
这是我，因为她不想离开这个社区，我们看了一个靠近布鲁克林市中心的地方，我们正在考虑出租，我告诉一位女士，哦，我们真的想留在这个社区，她说，好吧，我们有一个地方。
No, it's exactly right.
不，完全正确。
She said, we have a place that's not a rental though, it's for sale.
她说，我们有一个地方，不是出租，而是出售。
And then I looked at it.
然后我看着它。
She showed it to me and I said, oh, I think that's our apartment and I showed it to her and we were the first birthday, let's see it.
她把它拿给我看，我说，哦，我想那是我们的公寓，我把它拿给她看，我们是第一个生日，让我们看看。
But then, anyway, we ended up getting it after some shenanigans.
但无论如何，我们最终还是在一番恶作剧之后得到了它。
But we wrote them a song, this lovely French couple.
但我们为这对可爱的法国夫妇写了一首歌。
We wrote them.
我们写了它们。
I saw that.
我看到了。
I sent it to you.
我把它发给你了。
Yeah, that was amazing.
是的，那太棒了。
That was amazing, yeah.
那太棒了，是的。
So this is another like New York real estate.
所以这是另一个像纽约的房地产。
Like you got to use everything you got.
就像你必须使用你拥有的一切一样。
You got to use everything there.
你必须使用那里的一切。
It is an emotional process, even for the seller because the seller was 12 or 15 bids on this place.
即使对于卖家来说，这也是一个情绪化的过程，因为卖家对这个地方进行了 12 或 15 次出价。
Like we had to get to the front of the line.
就像我们必须排在队伍的前面一样。
Yeah, that's really funny.
是的，这真的很有趣。
And there was something as a seller too, where you're like, especially if you had a real life there, you want to like pass it along to someone else that's going to build a nice life there.
作为卖家也有一些东西，你会喜欢，特别是如果你在那里有真实的生活，你想把它传递给其他人，以便在那里建立美好的生活。
And look what you've done, you have this lovely home, you have this lovely child, and that is your son's first place he gets to live in the world.
看看你做了什么，你有这个可爱的家，你有这个可爱的孩子，这是你儿子在世界上第一个生活的地方。
They had three children here and the couple before us had three children here.
他们在这里生了三个孩子，我们之前的夫妇在这里也生了三个孩子。
So our downstairs neighbor were like, they were like, this, that's a fertile apartment.
所以我们楼下的邻居就像，他们就像，这，那是一套肥沃的公寓。
People move in there, people move in their single and leave with a big brood, you know.
人们搬进那里，人们搬进他们的单身公寓，然后带着一大群人离开，你知道。
That is really funny, family band, family, it's all ends with a family band.
这真的很有趣，家庭乐队，家庭，一切都以家庭乐队结束。
I loved when Lily said you went to that brand name, law school, I know it makes you feel good and pretty.
我喜欢莉莉说你去了那个品牌的法学院，我知道这会让你感觉良好和漂亮。
The guilty Lily is very funny, guilty, I really fucked up Lily is a very funny speed for having him in both of these.
内疚的莉莉非常有趣，内疚，我真的搞砸了莉莉是一个非常有趣的速度，让他同时参与这两个事情。
This does feel like a two-parter.
这确实感觉像是两个人。
I liked watching these two back-to-back.
我喜欢看这两个人背靠背。
We did full disclosure, we recorded two episodes, we talked about that we did we did not not that guy before this and it really plays like an hour.
我们做了充分的披露，我们录制了两集，我们谈到我们之前没有那个人，它真的播放了一个小时。
I'm surprised by how often when we do two in a row it really feels like an hour.
令我惊讶的是，当我们连续做两次时，感觉就像一个小时。
I really like that about the show and there's sometimes it's a three-parter.
我真的很喜欢这个节目，有时它是一个三人组。
I'm proud of that.
我为此感到自豪。
It was a tough sell at first.
起初销售很艰难。
CBS didn't have a lot of sitcoms that did that or zero sitcoms that did that and I'm glad we were the one because it rewards that type of viewing.
哥伦比亚广播公司没有很多情景喜剧做到了这一点，或者零个情景喜剧做到了这一点，我很高兴我们是其中之一，因为它奖励了这种类型的观看。
Again, I think that's why people watch it after all these years over and over because it is Satisfying in the way that like you you follow the through line you it takes you on a ride that like it's taking you somewhere You watch three or four of them if they're the right three and four They kind of play like a little movie or certainly like a nice hour or something, and it's yeah I'm very proud of that.
再说一次，我认为这就是为什么人们在这么多年之后一遍又一遍地观看它，因为它是令人满意的，就像你一样，你沿着一条直线走，它带你踏上一段旅程，就像它带你去某个地方。你看其中的三四个人，如果他们是正确的三四个人，他们有点像一部小电影，或者肯定像一个美好的时刻或其他什么，是的，我对此感到非常自豪。
I did write a note Barney's plan is so dark Really doesn't I like what you said about his his energy shift later kind of saves it but he probably should have got the spanked a little somehow later in my camera.
我确实写了一张纸条，巴尼的计划太黑暗了，我真的不喜欢你所说的他的能量转移，后来有点保存它，但他可能应该稍后在我的相机里被打屁股。
I like the momentous step into adulthood, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, right?
我喜欢迈入成年的重要一步，突突，突突，突突，突突，突突，对吧？
To me, that one line is kind of like, A, this episode, but all of how I met your mother, right?
对我来说，这句话有点像，A，这一集，但我是如何认识你母亲的，对吧？
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
They're taking a momentous step into adulthood.
他们正在向成年迈出重要的一步。
And they're also like...
而他们也像...
And also chug.
还有嘎嘎声。
Chug.
突突。
Yeah.
是的。
That's the series in a nutshell, right there.
简而言之，这就是该系列。
That's certainly the early part of the series in a chug.
这当然是该系列的早期部分。
The comically large bottle of champagne was so many bars have that and you always wonder what's going on with that thing is anyone ever going to open that.
那瓶可笑的大瓶香槟很多酒吧都有，你总是想知道那东西是怎么回事，有人会打开它。
I love that Wendy says, I think there was a goldfish in there at one point when you made the sale quit selling.
我喜欢温迪说的，我认为当你停止销售时，那里有一条金鱼。
Do you have any made the sale quit selling?
有没有人让销售停止销售？
I love that line.
我喜欢那条线。
And Marshall's drinking it.
马歇尔正在喝它。
I think the next day it's just been open in the bar and he's just drinking it again.
我想第二天酒吧刚开张，他又开始喝了。
And we could just round things out, Josh, if you check out your text, Jordana has answered the question.
我们可以把事情搞清楚，乔什，如果你查看你的文字，乔丹娜已经回答了这个问题。
Oh my.
天哪。
brother's stepdad and named Crane Davis and she says they named it or he says actually they named it that way to create a name no yuppie would ever want to move into in the status obsessed 1980s down under the Manhattan Bridge overpass.
哥哥的继父，名叫克兰·戴维斯（Crane Davis），她说是他们这样命名的，或者他说实际上他们这样命名是为了创造一个在曼哈顿大桥立交桥下的 2980 年代，雅皮士不会愿意搬进的名字。
They were fighting the developers.
他们正在与开发商作斗争。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah.
是的。
That's great.
那太棒了。
Okay.
好的。
So I don't know where the fuck I was and I like felt like I never heard that.
所以我不知道我他妈的在哪里，我感觉就像我从来没有听说过一样。
No, it was like in my 30s.
不，那是在我30多岁的时候。
Yeah.
是的。
Okay.
好的。
That's cool.
这很酷。
That's cool to know.
很高兴知道。
But yeah, a great, a great episode and really fun.
但是，是的，非常棒，非常棒的一集，而且非常有趣。
And I love the reveal of the name at the end.
我喜欢最后透露的名字。
Like, I also really liked that when the letters came together that Lillian Marshall look up at the letters on the screen.
就像，我也很喜欢当字母组合在一起时，莉莲·马歇尔抬头看着屏幕上的字母。
They can see the word for me.
他们可以为我看到这个词。
They can see them forming the word and we're seeing the word.
他们可以看到他们组成这个词，我们也看到这个词。
It's very sad.
这是非常悲伤的。
That's a great, that's one of my favorite tags.
太棒了，这是我最喜欢的标签之一。
Well, remember this, we might talk about tags at some point with the office ladies.
好吧，记住这一点，我们可能会在某个时候与办公室女士谈论标签。
That little tag, that little final beat is so funny.
那个小标签，那个最后的小节拍太有趣了。
I like take that note.
我喜欢记下那张纸条。
Well, that's a good tag because we made it up to some of the office ladies.
嗯，这是一个很好的标签，因为我们为一些办公室女士设计了这个标签。
We're talking about favorite tags.
我们正在谈论最喜欢的标签。
I really like this one.
我真的很喜欢这个。
It's funny and it sets up a real problem.
这很有趣，而且提出了一个真正的问题。
You want to tune in next week to be like, Oh shit, they just sunk beyond their life savings into a place that smells horrible.
你想在下周收听节目时说，哦，糟糕，他们刚刚超出了毕生积蓄，陷入了一个闻起来很糟糕的地方。
And all right, please write into if you're a New Yorker and you walk by, I want to say somewhere in the upper 40s by the West Side Highway.
好吧，如果您是纽约人，并且您路过，请写信给我，我想说的是西区高速公路旁 40 多岁的某个地方。
There's a big, it is called a stupid treatment plan.
有一个很大的，叫做愚蠢的治疗方案。
It is labeled as a stupid treatment plan.
它被标记为愚蠢的治疗计划。
It doesn't always stink, but certain days, it really is always a cheapo right there.
它并不总是很臭，但在某些日子里，它确实总是很便宜。
Right to me and let me know if you've experienced that.
对我来说是对的，如果你经历过这种情况请告诉我。
It's a thing.
这是一件事。
Welcome back.
欢迎回来。
We are wrapping up this week's episode with our sea blood.
我们将用我们的海洋血液来结束本周的剧集。
Sea blood.
海血。
I don't know why, but it does feel natural.
不知道为什么，但感觉很自然。
Let's just go with it.
我们就这样吧。
It's just getting weirder.
事情变得越来越奇怪了。
This is where we read a letter from you, one of our listeners and a lover of how I met your mother, if you would like to send us a voice note or a written letter about what this show means to you, how I met your mother, go to how we madeyourmother.com, hwmym.com, go to contact, follow the instructions and here is this week's letter.
在这里，我们阅读您的来信，您是我们的听众之一，也是我如何认识您母亲的情人，如果您想向我们发送语音留言或书面信，说明该节目对您的意义、我如何认识您母亲，请访问我们如何制作yourmother.com、hwmym.com，前往联系方式，按照说明操作，这是本周的信。
Dear Josh, Craig, and Alec, it's nice that everyone includes you, Alec.
亲爱的乔什、克雷格和亚历克，很高兴每个人都包括你，亚历克。
I always, I enjoy it.
我总是，我很享受。
I know, it's nice, you're in it, you're part of it.
我知道，这很好，你在其中，你是其中的一部分。
My name is Jessica, I'm a fellow Hollywood writer who, like so many of your viewers, has remained such a fan of this show because of how beautifully it treats the concept of a chosen family.
我叫杰西卡，是一位好莱坞作家，和许多观众一样，我一直是这部剧的粉丝，因为它完美地诠释了选择家庭的概念。
Like Ted and Marshall, I met my best friend, Hannah, in our dorm room.
像泰德和马歇尔一样，我在宿舍里遇见了我最好的朋友汉娜。
It was the fall of 2005, coincidentally, the same year, him, him premiered, and less than a year later, I met the man I would eventually marry.
那是2005年的秋天，很巧的是，同年，《他他》首映，不到一年，我就遇到了我最终要结婚的男人。
Funnily enough, his name is Robin.
有趣的是，他的名字叫罗宾。
Shortly after we finished college, Hannah reconnected with a childhood friend of hers named Christa, and the three of us immediately formed a bond.
我们大学毕业后不久，汉娜与她儿时的朋友克里斯塔重新取得了联系，我们三个人立即建立了联系。
All of us were only children, and we grew to form a sisterhood.
我们都是独生子，我们逐渐形成了姐妹情谊。
Early on, I introduced them to himium, and it quickly became a reason for us to frequently get together, have dinner, ask philosophical questions such as, is this man a rabbit or a duck?
很早就，我向他们介绍了hiium，它很快就成为我们经常聚在一起、吃饭、问哲学问题的原因，比如，这个人是兔子还是鸭子？
And who would woo, and even set up a March Madness bracket a friend when she started using gating apps, a failed experiment, since the very first guy on the list was the guy she married.
当她开始使用门控应用程序时，谁会向朋友求爱，甚至为朋友设立了“疯狂三月”支架，这是一次失败的实验，因为名单上的第一个男人就是她结婚的男人。
We were inseparable for the precious years we all lived near each other in Denver, but in 2014 I took a big leap and moved to L.A.
我们在丹佛住得很近，形影不离，但在 2014 年，我迈出了一大步，搬到了洛杉矶。
to further pursue my career in entertainment.
进一步追求我的娱乐事业。
Much like Ted, I had a plan, work hard for a few years, make good connections, build up that resume, then move back home to buy the perfect house and live near my friends again.
就像泰德一样，我有一个计划，努力工作几年，建立良好的关系，建立简历，然后搬回家买完美的房子，再次住在我的朋友附近。
as Ted learned many times the universe doesn't work according to our plans.
正如泰德多次了解到的那样，宇宙并不按照我们的计划运行。
I stayed in LA working in an independent film and honing my craft as a TV writer for 11 years, writing the waves of several big moments of success and many more moments of failure.
我留在洛杉矶从事一部独立电影的工作，并磨练了自己作为一名电视编剧的手艺 11 年，写下了几个重大成功时刻和更多失败时刻的故事。
In the meantime, two of us got married and one had two wonderful children who, as Ted's children refer to his friends, call me Aunt Jesse.
与此同时，我们两个人结婚了，其中一个人有了两个可爱的孩子，正如特德的孩子们称呼他的朋友一样，他们叫我杰西阿姨。
As an only child, it's a title I had never expected to hear.
作为独生子，这是我从未想到会听到的头衔。
Through it all, him-yam was a constant presence from texting each other happy-slapsgiving or sending each other gifts of Marshall eating a sandwich every 420.
在整个过程中，他一直在场，互相发短信表示高兴，或者互相发送马歇尔每 420 秒吃一个三明治的礼物。
We are from Colorado, after all, to watching a hungover on the couch together the morning after my husband's 40th birthday.
毕竟，我们来自科罗拉多州，在我丈夫 40 岁生日后的第二天早上，我们一起在沙发上观看宿醉。
Unlike Lily and Marshall, our marriage didn't ultimately make it.
与莉莉和马歇尔不同的是，我们的婚姻最终并没有成功。
And as I told the girls, the moment I knew we had to throw in the towel, I actually heard the sound of glass breaking.
正如我告诉女孩们的那样，当我知道我们必须认输的那一刻，我实际上听到了玻璃破碎的声音。
In 2025, the industry collapsed, had me wondering what else was out there.
2025 年，这个行业崩溃了，让我想知道外面还有什么。
I learned that a university in England was offering a master's degree in magic and occult science.
我了解到英国的一所大学正在提供魔法和神秘科学硕士学位。
And I knew I had to go.
我知道我必须走了。
When I told my niece, I was basically going to grown up Hogwarts.
当我告诉我的侄女时，我基本上是要在霍格沃茨长大的。
She was thrilled, but astutely asked, won't that make it harder for you to come visit?
她很激动，但又敏锐地问道，这样你来拜访会不会更困难？
It's been an amazing ride out here in England and I intend to stay in London for the foreseeable future, though it is indeed difficult to be farther away from my chosen family.
在英格兰这是一次奇妙的旅程，我打算在可预见的未来留在伦敦，尽管确实很难远离我选择的家庭。
What a blessing it has been to have discovered this podcast.
发现这个播客真是一件幸事。
Now we're all rewatching the show for the five thousandth time rehashing our favorite episodes and learning more about the BTS stories that made the show so special.
现在，我们都在重看该节目五千次，重温我们最喜欢的剧集，并了解更多关于使该节目如此特别的 BTS 故事。
As a fellow writer and producer, I admit, that's my favorite part.
作为一名作家和制片人，我承认这是我最喜欢的部分。
On that note, I'm extremely grateful to Craig and Carter for not caving to the network when they tried to make you ditch the serialized nature of the storylines.
在这一点上，我非常感谢克雷格和卡特，当他们试图让你放弃故事情节的连载性质时，他们没有屈服于网络。
The first episode I ever watched was drumroll, please.
我看的第一集是鼓乐，拜托。
And even though I hadn't seen the previous episode about the wedding invitation and didn't know these characters, it was the unusual storytelling and their sibling-like banter that got me on the hook.
尽管我没有看过前一集有关婚礼请柬的内容，也不认识这些角色，但不寻常的故事讲述和他们兄弟般的玩笑让我陷入了困境。
Thank you for trusting your gut and writing the show you wanted to write.
感谢您相信自己的直觉并写出您想写的节目。
authenticity is what made your viewers feel so connected to this fun and beautiful world.
真实性让观众感到与这个有趣而美丽的世界如此紧密地联系在一起。
I don't know what will be in store for me while living in London, but there are two things I know for sure.
我不知道在伦敦生活时会发生什么，但有两件事我确信无疑。
I'll always have my sisters, and it's going to be legend.
我将永远拥有我的姐妹们，这将成为传奇。
Wait for it, Derry, Jessica.
等等，德里，杰西卡。
That's great.
那太棒了。
I love that there's something magic about this letter coming because we're just talking about Harry Potter and Hogwarts and Derry Potter and Derry on Allie and like the magic of New York.
我喜欢这封信的魔力，因为我们只是在谈论哈利·波特和霍格沃茨、德里·波特和艾莉的德里，以及纽约的魔力。
It makes me want to hear more from like fans in London of like, like, what are those weird little, like, mythological and other fans in London?
这让我想听到更多来自伦敦的粉丝的声音，比如，伦敦那些奇怪的小粉丝和神话粉丝是什么？
I'm going to be doing a play in London this summer.
今年夏天我打算在伦敦演出一部话剧。
Fuck yeah.
他妈的是的。
It's called Hit Machine at the Soho Theater.
苏荷剧院的演出名为“Hit Machine”。
Basically, it's July through like mid-August.
基本上是七月到八月中旬。
Check it out, it's a great play by John Karen, Ben Harper's doing the music.
看看吧，这是约翰·凯伦（John Karen）的精彩表演，本·哈珀（Ben Harper）负责音乐。
It's a really cool, so bringing the fam over to London this summer, I'm really excited about it.
这真的很酷，所以今年夏天把家人带到伦敦，我对此感到非常兴奋。
And maybe I'll meet some people who are into the magic and occult sciences.
也许我会遇到一些热衷于魔法和神秘科学的人。
Go see it, go see the show, Jessica.
去看吧，去看演出，杰西卡。
You're part of the pod now.
你现在是 Pod 的一部分了。
We've read your letter, you go support Josh, come say hi.
我们读了你的信，你去支持乔希，过来打个招呼。
That was an awesome letter.
那是一封很棒的信。
Thank you for, I love how that letter covered this like epic scope of her life.
谢谢你，我喜欢这封信如何涵盖了她人生的史诗般的范围。
Like just shared this huge kind of portrait of very hymium style.
就像刚刚分享的这张巨大的肖像，风格非常hymium。
Like here's what my life has been ending in this completely unexpected new chapter that is so adventurous and weird.
就像这就是我的生活在这个完全出乎意料的新篇章中结束的事情，它是如此冒险和奇怪。
I'm sure Jessica herself couldn't have predicted that that's where it was all leading to.
我确信杰西卡本人无法预测这就是一切的结果。
It's great.
这很棒。
So update us.
所以更新我们。
and let us know how the magic of it all works out.
让我们知道这一切的魔力是如何实现的。
That's a great story.
这是一个很棒的故事。
Thanks for sharing it.
感谢您分享。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me.
请装备我。
All sins are forgiven in New York City.
在纽约市，所有的罪孽都被宽恕。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任监制。
And it's presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
它由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 提供和分发。
The show is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
该剧还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛担任执行制片人。
And the show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作和编辑。
Our co-producer is Doug Madica.
我们的联合制片人是道格·马迪卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves, a point of blue studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Alex Reeves，他是 blue studio 的一个点。
And our Gen Z Masters, our digital content producer, Emily Blumberg, an associate producer, Catherine Grove.
还有我们的 Z 世代大师、我们的数字内容制作人 Emily Blumberg、副制作人 Catherine Grove。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help to spread the word.
它确实有助于传播信息。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《New York City》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Sam Theobold and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢 Sam Theobold 和 Elliot Connors。
Go to HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，然后单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at JoshRadner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的 Muse Letters，并在 JoshRadner.com 上查看他的音乐和其他所有内容。
Order Craig Thomas's debut novel, that's not how it happened, wherever books are sold, and read his other published writing at CraigThomasWriter.com.
订购克雷格·托马斯的处女作，无论哪里有卖书，事情都不是这样发生的，并在 CraigThomasWriter.com 上阅读他出版的其他作品。
And you could subscribe to my own Dead Father Society on Substep.
你也可以在 Substep 上订阅我自己的亡父协会。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise funds for congenital heart disease research.
要了解您如何做出改变，这展示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动。
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
查看我们网站顶部的“Make a Difference”选项卡。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。
real question it just hit me am I in love with you or just New York City
真正的问题让我震惊，我是爱你还是只爱纽约市